morning gentlemen how are you so we're
just we're going to start um I don't
think there's a ton to go over anyway uh
from my perspective but um if any of you
gentlemen would like to join us up at
the mic and just to discuss uh the issue
in general and also the amendment that
we have before us that would be that' be
great I don't think this is a
controversial bill but seems pretty
straightforward
um so what we're looking at in front of
us is um a a new definition in statute
for station Weare uh because we don't
have that right now
correct and um we want to be able to do
that so we can differentiate between P
between the personal protective wear and
the station wear correct correct so that
we can work towards um firefighters not
having to wear past lated stuff until
such time that hopefully we get new
equipment that isn't ladened with that
but also doesn't burn I'm understanding
so far yes all right so um the um Fred
for your benefit uh the amendment to the
amendment that I have in front of me or
at least a proposal of one I haven't
brought it to OS yet um if you look at
page two line nine um we've adjusted the
safe alternative to current firefighting
personal protective equipment um if it's
designed um from the requirement shall
be required to should a preference being
given to it so if that new equipment
comes on the marketplace fire stations
aren't required to pick it up but um
they are encouraged to pick it up as
they're going through the regular
replacement that they would normally do
correct yeah so uh Gear replacement um
by manufacturer date is good for 10
years before it needs to be replaced um
and what we were trying to avoid was to
put municipalities in uh a position
where there was some sort of UN funded
mandate to say You must purchase
whatever gears on the market that meets
these requirements um instead we think
that there's enough uh we're leaning on
the manufacturing industry enough from
an international perspective to start
having these manufacturers develop this
gear over time um so as you mentioned is
it would just be encouraged um at that
point but I do believe nationally at
some point there's going to be a drop
dead date on when you can have a gear
with known pfast manufactured any it so
trying to get ahead of it yeah and
assuming ah Peter how are you now we're
official yeah um assuming of course that
uh they are able to develop gear that
doesn't use pep fast in it correct
because it's still the safest thing we
have on the market correct yeah it's
still the safest for for an uh what we
call an idlh which is immediate danger
to life and health um there is I I don't
don't I don't want to give you the
manufacturer name because I don't I
don't remember if I'm 100% correct on it
um but there is one manufacturer right
now who's saying that they'll have this
developed soon um I do know that we have
uh one fire department and and it
happens to be here in conquer that is
looking to U move forward with the
purchasing of this gear um so it is on I
wouldn't say the immediate Horizon but
it's coming close okay um backing up
just a sec to line one uh the
manufacturer person selling fire
fighting personal protective equipment
and the purchaser of purchaser of the
equipment shall retain the notice of the
procurement files for at least three
years from the date of the transaction
um first
off that's the notification of whether
or not there are p fases in the material
what's the purpose of the three-year
Mark so that is what's in current law um
so we're not proposing that we would
change that
um what we're looking to change is Right
Now by law if the gear has p in it the
manufacturer has to send a letter um and
that letter goes in the personnel file
uh indefinitely and then remains in the
procurement files for the Department for
three years I don't know why they landed
on that um that was before my time but
what we're trying to do is because the
manufacturing industry is uh many of
them are saying no our gear does not
have p in it we want to change the law
to make sure that that notification
comes regardless of what the claim is if
they say the gear has no p in it we also
want that on file y um and then we want
a copy of the same to be provided to the
employee which is not a current uh uh
under current law right now we want the
the physical employee to have a copy of
that letter yeah so they know what
they're wearing y okay and then um oh
Peter
so Brian what kind of push back you get
from manufactur I mean I toally I
totally get the idea that you want that
in there
because they need to put that stuff in
there to make the gear
work uh I'd say
yes then and that the firefighter has to
we that
get kill
fire injur it's a trade
off fact has to be clear that he's
wearing that it's kind of like you're
taking the risk by being a figh lots of
R but this is one of them that you
should at least have a record of
because otherwise I mean it's just not
right not to not to have theity if the
manufacturers say it's not in there then
that should
be it's a cim right yeah um thank you
representative for the question we want
to make sure that that manufacturer is
on record um stating it does or it does
not have it in it I will say um I'm
unaware of it happening here in New
Hampshire as of yet um but there has
been this is a international issue um
and there has been a number of lawsuits
that are now currently being worked
through um with manufacturers saying our
gear does not have pasas in it uh and
scientists saying that it does in fact
have it in there so um the International
Association of firefighters is fighting
against the National Fire Protection
Agency as well as uh gear
manufacturers and that's when I say that
uh our organization is leaning on these
manufacturers to make these changes
that's the intended effect here is just
to put uh pressure from a New Hampshire
perspective um to say that we're not
we're not going to do this
anymore we're not going to what we're
not going to put our firefighters in a
position where they are known to be
exposed to past chemicals well if
there's if there's a VI if there's an
alternative I remember we we had a
build maybe 10 years ago right there was
a big issue about firefighting phones
and so forth and so on and Adam you
probably remember uh that um that there
was an
alternative maybe it was completely
harmless but it was a lot better than
that bu back right
remember yeah so um that's exactly it
right now is there is no alternative um
and it is has been proven that the gear
with P in it it's almost a roll of the
dice whether or not you're going to get
cancer but certainly if you were to go
into an a a fire without this gear on
you would not survive so that's the
tradeoff um when there becomes an
alternative then it becomes harder and
harder for either a municipality or a
manufacturer to not provide that
alternative and that's what we're trying
to
accomplish so you're yes
okay with that um I am yeah no that
sounds good any other Fred anything up
until this
point correct they have uh there are
certain manufacturers that have um been
able to identify uh firefighter turnout
gear is comprised of three
layers um that's how it's constructed uh
some of those layers they've been able
to uh identify Alternatives that do not
have past in it what they're struggling
with is to find a safe alternative um
for the uh water and oil repellent and
that's essentially what is that's what
they're using the past for as a durable
water and oil repellent so that you
don't go into a fire and get your skin
wet to the point that you burn kind of
from the inside of your gear out um so
and that's that's the key word here or
the key words is safe alternative um
we're not looking to
identify um turnout gear that has no P
Fass in it but is not going to protect
us within a fire either we and that's
why we drafted it the way we did was we
wanted to make sure that this
alternative is proven to be safe um
we're not just going to take any any
gear off the street without making sure
it's tested and proven first and and
once again it's not required anyway it's
just strongly encouraged in the language
of of the bill or the new so uh Peter
that would be line nine and 10 um the
proposed amendment that we're talking
about right now would strike shall be
required and is replaced by should give
preference to an alternative as part of
the existant existing personal
protective equipment yeah on page two on
page two two yeah you'll see it it's
it's in lighter on yours but be
reking that and changing it to should
should yep and and that's for um as
Brian was saying maybe just before you
came in um not downshifting costum
municipalities into some smaller fire
departments if for example a safeer
alternative came out but it was two or
three times the expense uh because of
the manufacturing type they didn't want
to push that onto a smaller fire
department they can have that
conversation on whether they give their
guys cancer in their own town I suppose
um or or how often potentially they have
to put that stuff on if it's once every
you know nine months or I don't know
what happens in the volunteer
departments it's kind of all over the
map yeah okay so so that would be a
conversation that could be had any other
questions from the committee though up
through line
11 were there any issues before I came
no I don't think so everything's the
major differences between the original
um bill and the amendment you were here
for so we could talk about the
underlying bill but um let's see so uh
moving on then uh line 12 uh I only had
one question on lines 12- 16 it says
until such time that a safe alternative
is provided to the employee fire
department shall have in place a policy
that limits the unnecessary exposure to
figh or fighting uh Personnel protective
equipment nothing in this subsection
shall refute that it Remains the best
practice for firefighting personal
protective equipment to be warned while
operating in an environment that poses
an immediate danger to life or health um
my only question Mr R on that
is obviously this would this would put
pressure to give preference to not
wearing the equipment as much as humanly
possible are you at all concerned that
this opens up the risk that a fire chief
will go too far and not have his men
wear it in a toss-up situation and then
somebody ends up getting injured sure um
I appreciate the question I I don't
believe so um in fact we've been working
closely with the fire chiefs on this
issue to make sure that we get it right
because we don't want um it's not our
intent to put fire chiefs in a position
where they can't lead and do their job
um so one of the things that came up was
for instance training what about putting
our firefighters in gear while we're
training is that um are we going to get
in trouble for that quite frankly a that
happens
now with P knowingly in the gear um and
it's not created an issue here in New
Hampshire um secondly
the we we chose our words carefully um
in using unnecessary exposure um if a
fire chief determines that exposure
quote unquote to be necessary that gets
them off the hook for for any wrongdoing
so the the point here is uh each
individual fire chief with had the
autonomy to look at their policies from
within many policies are just created by
fire chiefs many um have a Labor
Management component where they work
together to develop policies um but
essentially they would develop a policy
put it in place that says um you know
for instance where I work in Portsmouth
um you will wear you will wear your gear
in an idlh environment as we spoke of
earlier um or for any vehicle
extrication or uh relevant training or
anything of that nature um all this
would do would force departments to
create their
policies
that determine what is necessary and
what is
not and what oh go ahead no go
ahead uh immediately dangerous to uh
life and
health so what are the ramifications if
um these policies are put in place and
then somebody questions and and wins
that the fact that it wasn't necessary
and they required them to wear it or
vice versa um an injury or um disease
occurs arguably for that reason sure
like can they sue can they like what's
the um we have not put anything in place
that would determine that but what I can
say is determining whether the wearing
of turnout gear is necessary or
unnecessary um to my knowledge across
the board is subjective in nature um
because for instance we met may tell
someone they have to wear their
firefighting turnout gear to do vehicle
extrication but another department may
have specialized gear that they wear to
do vehicle extrication um so really it's
going to be it would be extremely
difficult to identify whether or not you
put someone in gear and they said that
was unnecessary exposure well take
training for instance a fire chief might
determine that we need to crawl around
and do search and rescue training we
need to do that with our gear on um so
he's determined that or she has
determined that to be necessary
necessary potential exposure um and if
it's unnecessary for instance um what
this is trying to curtail is those
firefighters going out um and doing uh
veeh or um excuse me traffic details or
standing by at a a power line down and
they're wearing their turnout coat um
this is what that's trying to to C tail
yeah yeah but there are no civil or
criminal there's we have not put
anything in place for that I I
unfortunately
I um I'm more comfortable if it's not
there I'm just yeah yeah yeah not having
spoken with with you know any civil
attorneys on this I don't know if
there's exposure there
but it doesn't look like there is any in
statute unless it was somewhere um
around I can go back and look at 5 154
A8 in that section and just see if
there's any but it's certainly not in
the amendment or the original bill as
proposed so and and I could um also
speak to the policy that we're trying to
make sure is in there um to some degree
that already exists under the
presumptive cancer law as well um in
order for firefighters to get the um the
benefit of
presumptive among other things their
department needs to have a policy in
place that follows best practices as
it's defined by um the New Hampshire
fire academy so that something very
similar to that already exists we're
just trying to build upon that okay any
other questions or comments you're G
check yeah I'll check on I'll check on
that yep and make sure that I get it I
mean certainly have a
situation like
foot say okay we're going to do a run in
ordinary clothing right but you realize
in a game when you got when you got a
equip on you can't do that put I mean
the helmet protects you but it also
restricts your
visibility you protect your
ball head all the way around and you
can't do that with helmet sure and
that's why so having a written stated
policy I yeah you want to have that in
place otherwise then it
becomes and again the policy is going to
Define what is necessary and what is not
that's the key here is the you said if
you're standing around waiting for
something and you're wearing that gear
right that does any
reason R any thoughts you good okay um
so moving on then uh this is where the
major differentiation between the
original Bill and this comes in line 17
through line 22 uh beginning Jan uary
1st 2025 fire departments shall not
provide as an option the purchasing of
firefighting firefighting station wear
that contains intentionally added pasas
before it was just that you couldn't
wear them period um with the fire
resistive uh chemicals which contain
Florine chlorine bromine lead or animon
um and beginning July 1st
2025 uh so pushing it out 6 months uh
fire department shall not provide as an
option the wearing of the same
manufacturers of firefighting station
where shall provide fire departments
with safer Alternatives should they
exist um I'm assuming that the reason
for pushing out the wearing is it would
give one purchasing cycle for people to
make the transition is is that the idea
behind that correct yeah this came up um
when the during the public hearing and I
believe it was representative leakas who
brought up his concerns um while he
appreciated we were trying to avoid uh
any unfunded mandate he saw the
potential here with the prohibition uh
of purchasing and the prohibition of
wearing occurring on the very same day
um so the the idea here was um if this
gets signed into law um it would be
signed in by July 1 of this year which
would get one full year um for an
employee to stop wearing that that
station wear um and the employer
provides new uniforms for them to wear
or uniform allowance so that they can
purchase
onp uh station Weare and and when does
that usually come out January 1st uh
when does the the allowance forch it
varies um I wouldn't say it's a it's a
hard and fast rule that it's January 1
in fact um ours I think uh begins on
July 1 um and it goes with the fiscal
year um but in I don't want to say all
cases because I don't know that for sure
but I would say I believe that in all
cases there's uniform allowance that
occurs annually or purchasing of
uniforms that occurs annually so there
should be no reason why this can't um
this this can't be taken care of then
and I do want to point out that um it's
simply stating that the employer cannot
provide as an option the wearing of that
so essentially that shifts the burden to
the employee to say because most
departments have uniform options that
they can wear it just removes that as an
option um so in the example that you
just gave though of uh July 1st because
we would be coming up on that within the
next few months um being when somebody
gets their um
allowance if this wasn't clearly
communicated before that time for some
reason and they went out and bought all
their station where they arguably
wouldn't be getting a new allowance
until July 1st of the following year
which is your deadline for no longer
being able to wear that equipment
correct correct so that would put them
in a situation of at least knowing a
year ahead of time but maybe not quite
having enough time to pick up the
equipment would that be accurate what I
can tell you is if you were to and this
is just strictly for uniform shirts and
pants if I were to order uh a pair of
uniform pants or a uniform shirt i' get
it in a week it's not is not it's not
difficult to to find there are um uni
form apparel companies all around us
that um it's readily available so and
and not only that but it's not like fir
fighter turnout gear where it cost
$5,000 to outfit someone you're talking
about a pair of pants for 40 or 50 bucks
and a shirt for 20 so um if the dates
are off by a week or two one way or the
other I don't think it's going to create
a whole lot of anxiety
okay um any comments answer questions
from the rest of the
[Laughter]
committee um okay um anything else that
anybody else wanted to state I'm
assuming everybody else is in support of
the proposed
changes you guys usually chat about that
so yeah okay yeah we've we've worked
together on this to make sure that we
get it right because again um we have uh
you know when we talk about the
relationship between labor and
management sometimes uh we're we're
heading towards the same goal but we
just get there differently so we wanted
and that's the reason for some of these
changes or proposed changes to the
language is to make sure that uh we get
it right to satisfy uh all the groups
involved okay perfect um for the
committee uh anybody philosophically
opposed to anything that we've heard in
the all right um so here's my proposal
then um I will look
into civil and Criminal stuff just to
make sure I'm I highly doubt anything's
in there I just want to double check and
make sure before we go running this
through um and you're going to check
that one place we talked about yep
double check yeah I'll double check that
just to make sure that there's no
conflict otherwise philosophically it
sounds like we're all probably on the
same page this seems very reasonable um
I will uh get the amendment printed into
an official form and then the next time
we meet as a subcommittee to look at
some of our other ones will just vote on
this one and send it to the full
committee who's missing Jason missing
Jason and Steve Boyd we haven't had
Steve here
yet yeah so does that sound reasonable
or any
concerns all right so uh yeah so barring
that guys I think this will
probably sail I think I don't think
you'll see any I don't think any major
resistance to yeah I I I feel like it
was pretty widely reported early on it
was just that date change that needed to
be modified so yep all right well thank
you having said that I'll close the uh
the work session uh for the subcommittee
on 1352 and uh we'll pick it back up the
next time that we meet
thanks
all right good morning everybody uh I
want to thank the committee for lasting
through a major load of bills today is
our last hearing on our original bills
we we should be getting many of these
out of the way we have next week off
unless your subcommittee decides to meet
but that's between you and your and the
rest of you um and if we get any second
committee bills I plan to hear them on
Wednesday the 6th with an exec session
on any bills that have come come out of
subcommittee afterward so uh Reserve
that day other than
that um March is entire and the 13th is
the plan date for all the rest of our
bills and beyond that the subcommittees
will be working all through March
so all
right chair yes so seventh we don't have
session then yes scheduling the exact
session I don't
know I have heard rumors both that we
will and that we won't I think it
depends on how many bills the other
committees get out this week uh at least
one committee is meeting today to exact
and education had a whole slew of them
yesterday so they're probably going
we're not going to be able to get away
with from all those 10 10 votes
and repetitive debates on in education
all
right house bill
1328 is there anybody here who cares
about
it well do you want me totr well
representative Schmidt standing up let
him introduce
it I just
saw
what I don't care either
way that's my question
all right so we're opening the public
hearing on House Bill 1328 and
representative Schmidt is here to
introduce
itk you madam chair uh happy to
introduce representative PRS Bill House
Bill 1328 relative Public Safety
providers defined as essential
Services um and it's a very brief bill
as you can all see uh just one line
basically First Responders are essential
Services providers so uh I I won't take
any questions but that speaks for itself
thank you thank you representative
Schmidt all right is there anyone else
who wishes to testify on House Bill
1328 seeing none I'll close the public
hearing and go into EX session represent
gr you had a motion I do um Madam chair
I move a to pass on House Bill
1328 okay Al Pat do you wish to speak to
your
motion yes thank you I think by defining
um emergency First Responders to this
gives them the same um status that other
First Responders have and I think it's
rather self-evident but if it's
something something that people want to
put in the statute I'll support that
okay thank you representative
gold oh additional comments I I think
representative grotus said it all all
right any representative
leus just like
uh I mean not having heard anything
about this what what are the
consequences or the effects of naming
them as uh essential service providers
what do they get something
other uh I believe it's something in the
Emergency
Management well it gives them the same
Authority in law if they're considered
essential workers just like uh Public
Service fire departments law enforcement
and this can give them for example the
if an emergency situation should it come
up then they are considered part of the
team and also I believe that I do we do
have other things in statutes that these
emergency that this um this type of
management Emergency Management has in
as far as
um access to uh counseling if they need
it you know that type of thing Ah that's
very true I was just wondering yeah if
anybody else has any more information
not opposed to this I'm just wondering
what I'm voting on he just puts them in
a category that they have the same job
related um pressures and status that the
other people who are involved with
emergency response have okay thank you I
think that's probably the the Genesis is
because representative PR is involved in
that uh counseling uh Team
representative Simon thank you madam
chair also not opposed to this on
principle at all I mean it seems
reasonable um just looked up the um
statute that's referenced and um
literally are just putting First
Responders are essential service
providers at the end of it our first our
essential service providers
typically
um is that typically in statute that we
put that I mean it is okay I just don't
know where else that is located sorry
yes yes represent maner py and then
Brown thank you um Madam chair just a
quick question uh F responders include
police fire and are the Emergency Room
Physicians if it's in a disaster would
that become a First
Responders that's a First Responders are
already defined in statute as you can
see in the bill it's
emergency emergency Public Safety fire
law enforcement telecommunications or
dispatcher emergency response Emergency
Medical Services Emergency Management
Public Health clinical care Public Works
and other skilled support Personnel so
that the um backhoe operator that's
helping out at an accident could be
considered any anyone else Brown yes
thank you Sor thank you madam chair so
looking back at the the the governor's e
the order one of them it it does say
that industry sectors that provide
essential Services etc etc those deemed
essential will continue to have the
ability to cross state borders for work
related to
travel um and transporting products Etc
and I know that from my history uh uh
we've talked about this the
town if you can identify essential
workers then you know the people that
you can tell to stay home in an
emergency that you don't need to have
come in and unnecessarily traveling and
there's also certainly FEMA has also has
a whole list of uh they don't call it
essential workers and I wish I could
remember what the but they have a c 12
categories that Define in an emergency
who should be working and who should be
staying home ah okay I'm not surprised
that FID divides them into 12 categories
rather than two or three but that's the
federal government for you or anyone
else yeah I'd like to say I'm not sure
this is entirely necessary but it
certainly seems
innocuous okay anyone else all right the
clerk can call the role oh excuse me
representative Simon you you just just
queuing up I don't know I I was going to
say
um if if there is such a thing as an
essential service provider whether it's
innocuous or not it just seems to me
like that these people would fit into
that category if such a thing is a thing
thing then I don't know who else would
fit into it if not these people
exactly yes represent chair it might
also have something to do with FEMA
reimbursements or of those things of
that nature
too yes we don't know enough about FEMA
reimbursement to really be smart about
it you are so correct representative
schmi all right
FEMA um and other things all right
anyone else
that case we do have a quorum uh the
motion is ought to pass by refes Gro and
the clerk can call the
role representative Simon yes
representative lakas yes representative
Bailey
yes representative Dolan yes the clerk
votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative
Brown yes representative gr yes
representative this keeps cutting out
excuse me representative Schmidt yes
representative
goalie
yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith yes representative mapy yes and
the chair yes 16 a0 n all right is there
any objection to consent the motion
passes 16 to
zero
not seeing any we will put this one on
consent
and we have a short break until
10:30
they they just
to right
being 10:30 I'd like to call the public
hearing for 1622 into order and welcome
the esteemed representative Carol
Maguire to introduce the
bill uh thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee House Bill
1622 is dare I say it a housekeeping
Bill to clean up some of the issues in
the administrating rulle making
process and it is a request of the
office they will be able to explain most
of the details I will point out the last
two sections number seven and eight
which are the ones I'm most proud
of section seven
says that if
a if an agency levies findes after a
rule
expires or assessed
fees from an expired rules that then the
agency shall refund all fines and
fees that is uh bet that has been the
rule in oplc for the most part other
agencies have insisted they didn't
collect
any but since a an expired rule is not
valid then they can't collect fees and
fines that are only in the rule so this
will say give it
back uh section8 says says that if an if
a rule is
expired when they're uh proposing
read-option then they have to provide a
written report on what happened while
the rule was expired um if we've had one
this year where it was expired for a
week and a half and they basically said
we just didn't do anything on that for
the week and a half another one had been
expired for 12 years years and it took a
little more effort for them to explain
what they' done but this way they each
agency that de has an expired rule has
to think about it and report it prior to
the Jael car meeting so I think those
are important and the rest of it is as I
said minor cleanup I also am presenting
a Germaine Amendment 0306 H which I've
distributed this is an addition also at
the request of the Jael car staff mostly
on timing so uh if you want to talk
about the details the jail car staff is
here ready to answer your
questions if you want to talk principles
I'm glad
to thank you any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony Michael morel OS
rules good morning I'm Michael moral I'm
the director of the administrative rules
unit within the office of legislative
Services um I can answer questions or I
can briefly go through the bill uh
whatever the committee would
like uh yes representative leas it would
be helpful to just briefly go through
the changes in the bill and the
amendment as well I agree
if you wouldn't mind thank you um the
first two sections of the original Bill
uh deal with changes regarding the
office of professional Li Insurance
certification
oplc
um one it talks about uh records of the
boards uh right now it appears that the
uh recordkeeping requirements varies
significantly between the uh between the
bo boards uh some I think do not even uh
mention it um so this would simply
require the boards to specifically
within their rules um specify a date for
perhap perhaps three years for record
retention it could be whatever they
wanted
um the second
portion um right now it says
licenses shall be valid for 2 years uh
we thought this should also include U
initial licenses registrations
certifications and renewals uh just to
be clear that it includes all of
those um section three of the
bill it's about certification and
Publishing of administrative rules when
an agency goes through the rul making
process and adopts a rule they then file
it with us and it becomes effective um
however that's not the end of the
process there's a back and forth with
the agencies uh regarding small edits
typos Etc uh my office also puts in
Source notes just like you have at the
end of rsas so you can backtrack and see
what changes there have been the same
thing is done for the rules and our
office does that and it applies to every
single section
um this would
uh require this would uh help the
process right now it can be six months
maybe even more uh before a rule finally
gets certified at which time we publish
it on our website um part of that is due
to uh backlog for us part of it is due
to the agencies just sitting on the rule
and not doing the certification I
understand that's a lower priority for
agencies but it needs to be done so this
would put into effect uh some Provisions
that we think would speed up the process
one big thing it would do is as soon as
or shortly after receiving an effective
rule an adopted rule from the agency we
would publish that online right now it's
not published until after it's certified
so it could be 6 months or more before
the public via our website actually see
a new rule and it's become problematic
uh both with the public and with the
agencies we get calls saying I thought
there was a new a new statute that uh
and new rules and yes indeed there are
they just not are they are just not
published so we hope that will uh Help
The Help the
process second ction for the bill deals
with interim rules those are rules that
are effective for 180 days and there are
specific reasons that agencies can use
this abbreviated
process
um right now there is no indication in
the statute that a agency can do a
conditional approval regarding a um
interim Rule and so that makes this
clearer that they can do
that
section five
um simply strikes um a
citation that's a housekeeping
measure section
six deals with declaratory uh judgments
uh if an um if an individual from the
public wants to uh challenge a rule they
can go to March Superior Court um this
would
um If U if there was a challenge uh it
also allows them U the individuals to
challenge that the agency has been
enforcing an expired rule by Statute
they cannot do that um therefore they
can challenge if an individual perhaps
has been fined but the agency did have a
fine rule that was still in effect then
that could be challenged and the court
would also have the authority to impose
uh Financial penalty on the agency
including payment of plaintiff's
attorney's fees
um and representative Maguire has
already addressed section 7 and
78 um
regarding the amendment to the
bill
um currently the process if an agency
files a rule within three weeks of an a
Jael car meeting which is the third or
fourth Friday of every month um then the
agency's rule will be taken up at that
meeting uh right now we find that
agencies are fing close to the deadline
uh we have to rule uh review all the
final proposals uh then agencies can do
conditional approvals and we've been
finding that by the time everything is
finished it's very close to the jail car
meeting and the committee members are
not having an uh adequate time to review
the proposed rules and comments so we
are requesting to change the uh deadline
to um allow for 30 days instead of 21
days
to have a final proposal on the agenda
for a specific
meeting
um we are also CH uh requesting a change
for conditional approval requests uh if
you don't know conditional approval is
occurs when an agency has submitted the
final proposal we've made comments on it
and then the agency agrees that yes we
should address these comments um so they
ask for a conditional approval from Jael
car to make these extra changes um right
now there's a 7-Day deadline for filing
the conditional approval request uh we
are asking that it be U placed 10 days
ahead of time um there are also amended
conditional approvals um there would be
a deadline of five days for those that's
that occurs when uh we review a
conditional approval
request we have further comments agency
says yes we want to address them and
right now is happening up to a day or
two before jail car
meeting section
[Music]
11 there is simply a citation change in
line
8 in 541a
135a
the revision to forms in section
uh there is an expedited process for
revising forms um because agency forms
are rules uh in the past it has not been
clear that they can do a conditional
approval on that the statute would the
amendment would specifi that that was U
possible other than that I would answer
any
questions great representative
gr um Mr moral you had mentioned that
the um the uh Bill addresses the record
retention of the boards which I
appreciate very much did it does it also
address and I didn't read it I could it
could be in here where the records are
going to be
kept usually it's within their offices
but since all the boards are attacked to
oplc um I would guess that it's being
done going to be done centrally uh with
oplc but Douglas osterhout The General
Counsel for oplc is here to testify and
perhaps he could better address that
thank you because that concerns me where
the records are thank you uh there was
one other point I wanted to make uh the
title of the ACT is relative to
administrative rulemaking and license
renewals by the office of professional
license Insurance
certification those are two separate
things but I could see that where
somebody would read this and think that
it covers um that it's all by the oplc
administrative rulemaking and license
renewals uh that may be why there are
not other agencies in attendance here we
have oplc and doj but and no other
agencies such as HHS or safety or dees
are here uh which concerns me a little
bit hello yes thank you so are you
saying that they may not be aware of
these changes it's possible yes okay
thank unless they went
into the bills and did a search for 541a
okay thank
you
Manti um will all the records be
electronic or will it be both electronic
and physical that way the storage is in
one place um I don't have the answer for
that I assume it's going to be
both
yes okay yep yep follow up after that so
the other that I'm trying to understand
is the gray area or the transitional
period 180 days they could use the old
rules while they implementing the new
rules the agencies can transition that
way is that my understanding is correct
or no uh that's not correct uh when the
agency adopts a role whether it's by the
commissioner or by a board and they file
it with us it becomes effective at 12:01
a.m. the next day unless they specify a
later date for effectiveness
uh once they once the effective date is
hit then it's the new rule that applies
regardless of whether it's been
published online by
US Representative
Schmid let's see thank you Mr
chairman um good morning Mike uh so uh
this is uh this bill and the amendment
are entirely the work product of your
offices as I have understood uh in
coordination or conjunction with oplc as
well so this is part of the process of
fine-tuning the Jael car process and to
some degree the oplc process as we go
along and discover that certain things
don't work quite as well as they they
might or that they should be codified if
they are working well is that
correct the bill is primarily our
requests um 541a is a fairly fluid
statute uh we always look for processes
that'll make things easier uh
particularly for the agencies um
sometimes we put burdens on them uh the
rulemaking process used to be much
simpler but it had no leeway at all for
any changes if an agency had a small
error they wanted to fix the only way
they could get it was preliminary
objection now there are options for
agencies
so it makes it a little more complicated
uh and it does require not yearly
changes 541a but fairly
frequent thank
you thank you Mr moral thank you Douglas
UT after your long break welcome
back
the S office of professional Li
Insurance certification forgot for a
second what it stood for look at me go
um where to start let's start at section
one the office isn't taking a position
on this bill but I do think there's some
confusion around our record retention
policies and I remember this argument
sort of coming up argument might be a
strong word but I remember this issue
sort of coming up when we were adopting
the PLC 100s I remember PLC 10
205 um and it's around record retention
and under our statutory Authority
31041 it says that the office will I
mean we can read it right here the
official record of the office of the
boards in accordance with the retention
policy established by the office uh I
heard the director testify that there
are multiple policies in place 57 boards
57 rules which is actually what we've
been trying to get away from over the
the last few years and I think we've
actually done that successfully so we uh
drafted
up a policy and we worked with doj on
this and we sent that to archives and
that policy was approved this predates
me but it's my understanding it took
about two years to get that policy
approved so currently from our
perspective all of the boards are under
the same retention And archiving policy
um the current current Ru making
requirements are actually under the
secretary of state right now in RSA 5
29331 uh that's five colon
29 30 and 31 um so so I
think I'm not sure we really need this
section because I think from the
office's perspective we have a unified
record retention policy that we've
worked on with doj we've worked we've
got approved by archives secretary of
state has the rulemaking authority from
our perspective it's a uniform process
and it's a policy that we have in place
um I think if we do proceed with giving
the office administrative rule I think
we need to be careful
about sort of again roles and
responsibilities so to answer some of
the questions um around oh and there's
there's another piece I want to bring up
before I move on I think might be some
conflicting language in rule but part of
our big push over the summer is um
having that contractor come in that
third party helping us revise the rules
for all of the boards and if there's
conflicting language there that's a
place we can clean it up I'm not sure we
necessarily need the ru making Authority
for for for that instance um and
[Music]
then where are the records kept
currently we keep some of the records in
the office um but we do box records up
we send them over to archives so they
are stored through the Secretary of
State in the archival process uh we are
in the process of are they paper or
electronic the answer is both we are
also we have a vendor um through the
state that is taking our paper copies
and also scanning them to make
electronic copies just for better record
retention so but the answer is still
both and we also even at the office now
um the majority of Licensing
applications are going to be paper
applications we're trying to go as
paperless as possible but for
individuals who may not have a computer
there's still paper options so I would
say it's leaning towards more electronic
but there is still
both
um the second piece section two not with
extending any other state law to the
contrary I kind of like this language I
think in the cleanup it's it's helpful
for us um I do want I
um doj raised the issue and I I think
they even think this might be too broad
an interpretation but we might want to
tighten that language up a little and
say something along the lines of
notwithstanding any other state law to
the contrary pertaining to licensing
terms I think the concern is when it
says not withstanding any other state
law to the contrary somewhere someone
along the lines is going to say well
that means discipline that means
revocation that means all of the things
I think that's a very broad reading but
we're trying to get out in front of that
um
interpretation uh the initial licenses
registration certifications and renewals
I don't think I have an issue with I do
worry if it's going to
be too limiting we are adopting so in
House Bill 518 which passed out of this
committee we adopted well we put right
in that language in RSA 310 that we are
using the definition of license under
541a which is essentially license
registration certification anything that
would require State permission so I I
don't necessarily think this language is
harmless I'm also not sure if we're
going to need it once licens once it's
very clear in RSA 310 that license means
all of those things in accordance with
541a so that that was in House Bill 518
which I we worked on in the fall I think
it was a retain Bill and an amendment to
that um so those are sort of my comments
on on sections 102 which pertain uh
explicitly to
oplc and then my only other concern and
this is
this is a weird position for me to be in
because I'm not really speaking on
behalf of oplc at this time I'm speaking
on behalf of somebody who's worked for
three separate state agencies and I do
have some concerns
about the the fee piece and the court
having authority to level Financial
penalties but I will use I'm going to
say a few things one I think oplc is
trending in the right direction I think
this committee gave the office fee
setting Authority which we didn't want
that 2s it gave us licensed processing
Authority which it did in the 300s all
of those are effective it says in
statute that you can't practice without
a
license I think in the future opl is in
a oplc is in a good
position regardless of the language in
this bill but I do have concerns that
I'm going to use oplc for an example if
we're in a position where we had
collected a fee
$155
fee we are now in a position where we
could be fined by the court paying
attorney's fees and have to re reimburse
that
$155 fee when the individual let's say
it's a licensing application fee then
receive their license so the
person received the benefit of paying
the fee and I don't want to be the
person up here saying oh the rules don't
matter they 100% do and we've pushed
really hard to make sure they do but I
think I have this weird perspective
because the oplc has been because of
these roles and responsibilities reliant
on other agencies for our Authority so
if the board fails to promulgate rules
it would be the oplc staff that suffer
the consequences for that and so I do I
am concerned that just Statewide we need
to take a good hard look at at how we
want to implement something like this um
again that's kind of speaking not as an
oplc attorney but as as somebody who's
worked for three separate agencies and
then the the other issue is I understand
that disciplinary action is often laid
out in statute but it's not always the
case and it's not always statute that
agencies rely on and we did a push again
in HB 518 where we created sort of a
list of uh disciplinary actions that
could apply to all boards and there
there were a number of reasons for that
we made the arguments there um but my
concern
is the wrong people suffer in this case
an administrative agency fails to take
action and they allow their discipline
their disciplinary rules to lapse I
think the harm falls on the public in
that instance because now the agency is
put in a situation where the choice is
to enforce a
rule and fear the retribution of the
court I that might be such a strong
verbage but you know what I'm trying to
say or allow the bad actor to go
unpunished and there there's a lot of
cases where I'm not sure I'm I'm
thinking back because I used to
prosecute prosecute uh APS rules and I
had an apsa case where an individual was
accused of sexually harassing an
individual with a developmental
disability in their care I worked with
police on that they said there's not
enough there to press criminal charges
it's not a case we can prove Beyond a
reasonable doubt they did not proceed
forward um but the standard at the
administrative level was lower and I won
that case and we were able to put that
individual on the registry and I fear
what had happened in that case if APS
had allowed their discipline to lapse
that bad actor would essentially be out
there still doing whatever bad actions
they did and I mean I I might be
thinking in two
two two extreme cases but these are the
kind of things from my experience uh
I've been with the state about six years
now I guess eight years uh three
different
agencies and so these are just the kind
of things that jump out at me when I
read the language I I'm
not rules are important we need them we
need them for due process we need them
for fairness people need understand
what's going on but I think we just need
to be very careful about what we do to
make sure rules are in place um and I
also the director testified to this and
and we had had a conversation before
this hearing I also would
like other agencies to weigh on us a b a
bit more because like I said I think
From opl's perspective given 518 given
655 last year uh given the 300s the 200s
the plc 10002s that that we are we're in
a pretty good place for this language
but I I think it needs more discussion
uh I've been up here for quite a while
talking uh but I'm happy to answer any
questions uh represent and then like us
thank you Mr chairman so I think those
of us who have uh some experience in
this situation uh recognize that uh that
this is a kind of a a tiger we've gotten
on board uh and uh that we're kind of
legislating on the Fly here so number
one is this is going to go to a
subcommittee we're going to have to work
this out I'll have to check with the
chair on there yeah right right so I I
would strongly recommend that because
some of these aspects simply have to be
worked out and we we can't decide this
on the Fly some of it needs to be
investigated and thought about in a way
that we can do in this process so um
that's the first question uh and uh um
so have you already my question to you
uh attorney o is um have you been
working with with administrative rules
unit on some of this because it sounds
like you're like you
haven't yeah yeah there we go Nike is
kind of funky okay it just took a second
to warm up right it's tired of me too
um we spoke this morning uh I saw this
uh we haven't really had a lot of
discussions about it I would
say I know where a lot of these things
are stemming from so we've probably had
discussions around some of this stuff in
the past but as to this particular Bill
not until this morning and I went over
and I just kind of told them what I'd be
testifying to so they weren't surprised
when I came up here
um yeah some of this stuff we can
clearly approve right off the bat some
of it we I think we need to have
something like a study committee to go
forward to to deal with this um but um
some of it needs to be and can be
immediately enacted but some of it can't
in my opinion so we have to work on
it representative
leus this question just on narrow Point
um so an earlier speaker said or at
least I took to imply that uh the
individual boards had rule making
Authority on records retention but from
what you said that's not the
case uh there we go all right I think
that may have been the case in the past
but our interpretation is that after 655
and sort of the unification of the
processes of boards that became an oplc
process I right we are the ones all the
boards fall under us we have all those
records physically electronically
so we follow the same process now
I as long as I've been here that has
been the way it has never been a
specific board sort of retention piece
when we look towards the individual
statutes for things like what could be
revealed to law enforcement for cases
that kind of thing maybe but not as far
as record retention policy keeping
things for seven years you know how we
archive those types of
things um
and and I I can I add one more thing to
is that the reason we we also did that
policy and worked with archives is
because there aren't any rules in
place representative grda and then
menipu and then goalie thank you U Mr
osterhout I'm going to challenge you a
little bit on that um because I don't
believe that I'm hoping that the answer
after 655 is that all boards keep their
records in the office but I don't
believe that that's the case I think
that some boards have their records out
of the office which concerns me because
that's some of that is confidential
information and should be part of the
record retention so can you confirm with
me that those records are solely held in
the office and not sitting around
somebody's credenza somewhere they
really shouldn't be sitting around
somebody's credena somewhere we have
fought very hard and I will use the word
fight because it's been a challenge um
but we did have individuals in the past
who had as you said records kept in
their garage in their wherever uh that's
something we are strongly strongly
against they're not all going to be
physically present at 7 Eagle Square
because they also go to archives for the
state and so those are maintaining
course right
so I would love to say
100% that you're not aware of of if we
became aware of we would try to track
those down but I would like to say it's
100% because it has been a big push for
us to get the records and if anybody
knows of a board member or individual
who doesn't or is keeping confidential
information in their garage please tell
me so I can track that down uh there is
another exception for individuals
working for us
for Contracting with the state um they
might be looking at files for um for
disciplinary purposes um but we still
you know we have those locked down
they're they're maintained
confidentially and we get them back so
that would be the only instance I can
think of where it wouldn't either be at
the office or with archives follow
follow up so is that um requirement that
the office has control over the files in
statute I think it is I think it's in
RSA 3
41e maintenance of the official so it's
the um duties of the executive director
maintenance of the official record of
the office and the boards in accordance
with the retention policy established by
the office and that is the policy we
worked with uh Secretary of State and
archives to develop and doj to develop
I and I'm also using that language to
get us the authority it's my
interpretation that language gives us
the authority to create that unified
process across all
boards good representative
Mani here um thank you for taking my
question um in terms of recordkeeping
you said you know it's partially
physical as well as electronic and
you're also uh you mentioned that it's
going to be scanned uh and so ultimately
the goal is to have electronic
records even if the application comes in
as a physical you're scanning it it's
stored rest you know archiving it is
electronic I think so for one it takes
up a lot of less space but also for
things like right to know it makes right
to know request and are answering them
much easier right so we can rather than
go dig through the boxes we can look on
the folder if there's any redactions
that need to be made we can do it on the
Fly and then we can send a response to
an individual electronically rather than
have them come through go through
archives come to the office dig through
everything have someone sit with them I
think it's it's better in the long run
for everyone um if we if we can move
them all to electronic so I think that
is the goal yes
follow I'm trying to find the parallel
in terms of electronic medical record so
now all the medical records are
electronic whether it's filled out or
whatever and we get the chart access to
our file as an individual so similarly
to follow where your tracking is where
the process is in your terms of
Licensing who has it where is it kind of
thing
is that the goal of OPC to maintain
electronic and the process so there's a
transparency in terms of the process we
say that's accurate
yes thank you Mr
chair it's like these mics are on a
Monday and just trying to wake
up I
noticed uh going to section
three and you being an attorney I'm
looking at some of these changes made in
section three looks like just a
semantics and wording you're really not
changing much other than someone's
personal preference on how they feel it
should be worded um can you tell me is
there really need for changing um I will
say first of all lines 14 and 15 um
version of the rule where it says which
the director shall publish online when
right after it it was already in the
statute that the director sh published
the adopted Rule and text
online I feel I think that probably gets
you to the same place
ultimately I don't have strong opinions
on it either
way and going down
[Music]
to we'll do this same thing on lines 19
through uh 23 um I understand putting in
the publishing or editing on line 20
process shall be shall notify the
director and I don't know why we need
who shall make where it says such
changes shall be made by the director
we're an original statute and I don't
know can tell me why it would be and the
rule shall be certified by the agency
when we're already talking about the
rule at the beginning of the
sentence I I I'm just looking at these
editings and it seems like we're people
are trying to make changes that really
don't need to be making work for
themselves that it seems like it's
saying the same thing and then I'll go
down
to line 24 agencies has reviewed the
edited language and agreed that is
certified version and then taking out
the anshell to put which be
published online by the
director I mean I think the and shall be
published online by the director is what
we're looking for so I'm not sure why
that's
struck this wasn't my language right so
it's probably better for somebody you're
an attorney so I'm asking if
reading I'm missing something yeah it's
interesting um I don't know I I think
some of it maybe just to shorten things
up make it a little more clear whether
it accomplishes something else I do
think that and and this
is there's there's a change
that how do I put this I have concerns
sometimes that rules get adopted they're
approved by jail car they're signed and
an agency adopts them and then I wonder
how the public is supposed to know about
that because the Gen Court website isn't
updated right away I think one of the
things here that if I'm reading it
correctly it would speed up that process
and give the public more access and I I
think I would be 100% in favor uh the
turnaround time on the agency is cut in
half but if we're talking about review
doing an editorial review of an already
approved rule that would I think be an
improvement for the public uh some of
these comments I I I noticed some of the
same things you did I didn't really feel
the need to address them here because I
thought they might be worked out um and
they're also they're kind of policy
decisions to me it was I read it as a no
harm no foul kind of that was my reading
on it um I I I didn't draft this
language so why the changes are in there
I can't really speak to
that any further
questions seeing none thank you Mr
estout uh JD laraby New Hampshire dep
Department of
Justice you can respond
afterwards
morning chairman honorable members of
the committee I'm JD lavali I'm a senior
Assistant Attorney General at the
Department of Justice um the department
isn't taking any position on the bill
but we just wanted to provide some quick
testimony this morning to highlight a
couple minor drafting concerns and just
um one uh potential consequence of the
bill um so I think as you heard uh oplc
testify we did uh when we saw the bill I
think on Friday we did let them know
that notwithstanding any other provision
of law um in section two the potential
concern there I think uh General Council
for PLC flagged that is just a crafty
argument could say not withstanding any
other provision of law you said my
license is is revoked or suspended well
there's notwithstanding any other
provision of law it's valid for two
years so that was the one concern From
doj's
perspective um in section four uh I
think this is actually just a um concern
in uh 54 1 a generally speaking but
section 4 addresses 541a uh section 19
and in section 11 and section 19 it
appears the statute contemplates boards
and commissions but doesn't contemplate
other public bodies that have ruem
authority such as councils or committees
uh so that might be something for uh you
all to um consider and then uh the heart
of the testimony from uh the department
of Justice's perspective perspective is
sections 6 and
seven I think you heard this morning um
uh you know the judicial branch oplc and
uh Department of administrative Services
were contacted for the fiscal impact
note uh but the Department's read of the
bill uh the cost could be potentially
more significant to the state um it's
clear under Section s potential State
revenues would be impacted uh because
any fees or fines improperly uh
collected would be required to be uh
refunded but under Section six uh the
Department of Justice resources would
probably be impacted uh if the bill
passed uh because of the potential
result in an increase in litigation um
so as section six goes
over uh right you can now or the bill
would allow for a lawsuit um agency is
definitely going to be a part to that
lawsuit but uh the agency is potentially
or the the state would be potentially
liable for a financial penalty and
payment of plaintiff attorneys fees so
you have uh an impact to the Department
of Justice you know litigation is
expensive uh both to the state as the
Department of Justice but then also uh
covering plaintiff's uh fees so we just
wanted to flag uh and I think the OS
director flagged as well I think the the
title of the bill may not have um
reflected you know all the state
equities uh across Statewide essentially
um so we haven't done a survey uh or
contacted other state agencies to be
clear so I'm not speaking on behalf of
DHHS or uh Department of Environmental
Services or other licensing or
administrative fine uh agencies but the
department just wanted to make sure the
committee was aware of the potential
impact uh so with that um I'm happy to
answer any questions the committee may
have thank you for your testimony any
questions yes representative
Schmidt Mr chairman so uh uh you were
here I believe when I asked my question
about whether this is going to
subcommittee this is turning into a
bigger and bigger can of worms as we
proceed with the hearing so uh would you
be available if it does indeed go to a
subcommittee for your council with
regard to uh board smithing because
there there are too many loose ends at
this point yes representative the
department would make somebody available
hopefully me but certainly somebody
thank
you other questions uh yes
representative Brown uh thank you Mr
chair do you see that there's a problem
right now for a person who may have paid
a
fee under an expired
rule for them to get
uh justice let's
say representative I'm not quite sure
I'm tracking but I I think I would go
back to
opl's council's comment where if it's a
fee for a license and they they were
issued the
license it's not yes it's all of us
sorry yes um I I'm not sure that's a a
question of Justice if
if the license was in fact issued right
if there's a processing um requirement
right I I just got my license renewed my
driver's license renewed and you know it
cost me geez I should know but it cost
me some some fee and uh and I got my
license now if the rule had been expired
and maybe I could demand from the state
agency the issuance of the license
without having paid the fee um but I
think that's a a little separate of a
question than um than administrative
fine but I do want to say that a
Department of Justice's perspective uh
we're not here to comment on the policy
we just wanted to make the impact
know certainly sir seeing of other
questions thank you very much certainly
sir um is there anybody who has not yet
testified on hb1 1622 who would like to
testify on hb1
1622 and Y one second Mr morl um
representative McGuire are you planning
on sending this to a study committee or
subcommittee sorry let's
do
okay okay if that's the case Mr moral if
you wouldn't mind we'll hold off until
the subcommittee meeting and you can
give whatever additional information
you'd like to there thank you um having
said that I will close the public
hearing on
hp22
thank you House Bill
1174 uh Mr representative
King
morning Madam chair members of the
committee uh thank you for having me
today uh my name is representative Seth
King I representative I represent Coos
District 4 which is Whitefield um
Jefferson and the town of Carol
um I presented this bill um because I'm
a freshman um representative and during
the campaign um I met a lady who was a
small business owner in my town and um
she had a we were talking politics and
she had an off-handed comment where she
said her husband is a plumber and he
would love to um have more apprentices
if he could but he's only allowed one at
a time so um I decided to look into that
further I asked OS um you know what
statute that was in and um they taught
me that it's not actually in statute
what they do is um uh we the legislative
body have given authority to oplc to
make rules on how many uh apprentices
plumbers are allowed to have at any one
time and um they have actually chosen uh
to only allow one Apprentice per
licensed plumber um I sent out the rule
to everybody here um it's actually the
third highlighted part um it's towards
the bottom of the page um and it
explains there there's the there's the
rule for you um and it is my opinion
that um that number is far too low so I
can't speak for people in the southern
part of the state although I have heard
uh similar complaints but I promise you
that up north in Northern New Hampshire
it is exceedingly difficult to find uh
plumbers when you need them um even if
you have an emergency it can be very
difficult to get somebody to come out um
and um I would stipulate that the reason
is is because for too long we have had
an
artificial um shortage on how many new
plumbers can be trained and brought into
the system so what my bill does is it
increases the number to three now the if
you read the language of my bill um it
can seem a little confusing first glance
um I just want to explain that this bill
does not mandate any licensed plumber
from having three uh apprentices at one
any one time matter of fact um you could
have no apprentices if you so choose
what this bill does is it tells oplc
that they still have the authority to
determine how many plumers a licensed
plumber or apprentices a licensed
plumber can have but that they cannot
have that number any less than three so
a plumber can have one Apprentice zero
apprentices two three um and maybe in
the future oplc will say you can have
four or five I highly doubt that's going
to happen they're probably if they have
for so long kept it at one they're
probably always going to keep it at
three but um this at least says from now
on plumbers licensed plumbers will be
able to have up to three apprentices and
this isn't going to be a Panacea this
isn't going to solve overnight all of
are Plumbing you know shortages but I
think that um in the long run this will
alleviate a lot of the problems we have
um with people finding um plumbers in
their area um furthermore um this will
also help
to um create more open jobs for people
just getting started in the workforce
you know if you're young individual and
you want to become a professional
something in the skilled you know labor
market um you know Plumbing might not be
an option for you if you cannot find
somebody who can train you if um if you
can't become an apprentice anywhere then
you're going to have to do something
else and that something else might not
pay as well it might not be your passion
um so so I think that this is going to
help increase the number of jobs for
plumbers and I think it's going to help
um the rest of us get plumbers when we
need them um I'd like to address one
other thing that may come up I'm not
sure who else is going to speak but um
interestingly and this was I think
completely coincidental um that the
Senate um has a bill almost exactly like
mine um Senator uh Keith Murphy put up a
bill um which is exactly like mine but
it says two instead of three and um the
day that he uh was going to testify on
that bill uh before his Senate committee
I talked to him about it and he said he
would prefer my bill quite frankly but
he went uh a little bit more
conservative just in the hopes that it
might pass I'm optimistic uh mine will
pass as well but um uh he spoke on it in
in his committee and then there were a
couple of people who spoke against it
and I would just like to address um them
because I don't know if they'll speak
again or if somebody similarly will
speak but um the day that they spoke in
front of the senate committee they said
they had just gotten the bill like 25
minutes earlier they didn't really have
time to wrap their heads around it but
they were against it because they were
afraid that this might put them um out
of compliance with the Department of
Labor and they didn't specify which rule
would put them out of compliance with
the Department of Labor i' I'd like to
learn if that's the case but I I I
suspect actually that they just
misunderstood the bill because I think
what they were afraid of was that this
was going to mandate that licensed
plumbers would have to take a minimum of
three apprentices and of course that's
not what I'm that's that's not what the
bill says but but if you look at it just
at first glance it almost kind of sounds
like that um but that's definitely not
the case um and if you just dig into it
a little bit for further I think you
you'd come to that conclusion so I think
that I think that they fear was um
unjustified um but if there is any sort
of rule with the Department of Labor
that might put them out of compliance
I'd happily look into that and we can
amend the bill or we'll see we'll take
from there but I I I suspect that's not
going to be the case when it's all said
and done so um I've definitely got many
other points I'd like to make as to why
this bill would be a good idea but there
are some um other uh individuals in the
audience that would like to speak as
well and I don't want to steal all of
their thunder so um I think I'll I'll
end it here I'll be happy to take any
questions thank you representative gold
and then man py
oh hi thank you madam chair and thank
you oh I can hear microphone's not gonna
cooperate here today uh my question was
did you talk you said you talked with um
op office of Professional Licensing opl
and um and so I was wondering did you
ask them about changing the rule no
actually I have not spoken with oplc I
spoke only with uh OS and I I wanted to
pinpoint where that rule was um and
there may be there may be a a method by
which um individuals can petition the
oplc to get it changed um I personally
am less than optimistic that they would
change I suspect that they want to stick
to that rule followup follow up um I
would encourage trying that change in
the rule I mean I'm just my question is
do you really think that legisl ating a
number versus the flexibility of rule
making and Rule changing is the a better
way to go well um I definitely didn't
want to write a bill that was going to
remove the authority altogether of oplc
um but I also understand that regulatory
bodies have a tendency oftentimes to be
overly conservative um
because they're afraid you know maybe
something happens and then it looks
poorly on them and this way they can
just be as conservative as possible
without that number being zero um but I
am a firm believer you know I've I've
lived in multiple countries I've
traveled a lot and um I watch television
of foreign countries and um I have seen
that there are a lot of states and a lot
of countries around the world where
their plumbers are fully capable of
training more than one individual at a
time I have a I have a very hard time
wrapping my head around the idea that
New Hampshire plumbers are too inept to
to train more than one plumber at a time
so thank you and I'm sure the plumbers
appreciate your uh confidence
representative maputi thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question
my question is have you looked at the
community college or the trade schools
in the state that are training and are
they having problem finding Apprentice
ship for their trainees in or in
training especially for Plumbing that's
a good question no I haven't but um
based on my limited research um even
even trade schools are are not immune
from this rule they they also have to um
if there's an apprenticeship they still
have to have a certain number of uh
licensed plumbers in order to have the
same number of licensed or apprentices
so thank
you thank you very much
representative thank you Mr Ted
Evans morning m madame chair and members
of the committee my name is Ted Evans
I'm a licensed plumber I've been a
licensed plumber since 1978 or so
whenever the State Licensing program
came about I've been a member of the
State Licensing Plumbing licensing board
under RSA 329 when it existed
and I did help uh with the
implementation of the gas fitting
portion of the law that resulted in 155
15327 to 38 so I'm pretty familiar with
the operations of Plumbing in New
Hampshire I was a contractor for a while
and then went to what we call the Dark
Side of Code Enforcement I became a
plumbing inspector and I did that for 14
years and the building inspector for a
number of others so I have experience
both in the trade and and as an
inspector I did training for apprentices
back in Manchester School in the early
90s uh I've done quite a bit of other
training for inspectors so let me see if
I can get the picture as we see it or as
I see it is that plumbing is not a
simple
trade it's very very complicated you go
to one house find one thing you go to
the next house you expect to say the
same thing you don't see the same thing
and it really does require quite a bit
of training and the tradition has always
been oneto one that you pair somebody up
with somebody who is inexperienced with
somebody who is experienced and then
that knowledge gets transferred over now
the way the rules are now I uh I can
acknowledge that if you have a big
company uh and you have 15 apprentices
and 15 licenses there's nothing to
prevent someone from putting one
licensed person on a job and having 10
apprentices on that job with them so it
doesn't really goes sort of more for the
shop than for any particular work
site and then there's a big division
between what we call new installation
and service work uh new installation is
maybe on the simpler side if we can call
it that but service work and repair gets
very very complicated because there's so
much different equipment out there from
so many different time periods that that
it's really
complicated so I'm opposed to the bill
because I think that onetoone
works if there's a problem with
attracting apprentices it's not because
we don't have enough opportunities for
apprentices it's that it Plumbing has
become an undesirable trade uh we're
dealing with human waste we're dealing
with things that are not pleasant uh
when I talk to young people they go
Plumbing I would never want to do that
so there's some of that going on there's
also and I think others can talk about
this more is that there's a problem with
uh training uh opportunities not
employment opportunities but training
opportunities if if this bill were to be
corrected I would like to see it put
money into trade
schools and attract people in high
school for this kind of work because
right now I don't think we have that
kind of thing going on um you can hear
from one of the other speakers that the
Manchester School of Technology is
lacking instructors in both Plumbing
electrical and and by the way it's a
same in other trades it has nothing to
do with plumbing being special and
needing more apprentices um the same
lack of workers or opportunity for
training happens in Electrical Plumbing
mechanical all the different trades
trades now is taken a back seat to
computer study and all those kinds of
things we have to realize that that's
what's going on here the other thing I
would like to say is
that the image to the public
shouldn't be that we have a lot of
inexperienced people running around
working on people's houses where easily
uh mistakes are easily made that could
impact Public Safety I mean that's what
we're talking about here is Public
Safety if we don't realize it we have to
is that the homes that we live in the
buildings we work in there's a lot of
potential dangers going on and if we
have inexperienced people working on
these systems we could be causing a lot
of problems
so I'm really kind of opposed on this
philosophically and practically but I
think efforts can be made in much other
much better efforts can be made in other
directions that would increase the
number of workers that we need in New
Hampshire I think I'll leave it there
and be glad to answer any
questions thank you
are with your experience in the trade
schools are you do have you found that
graduates of the trade schools can
cannot find an
apprenticeship I think apprentices have
have employment opportunities whether
they're up north or down here I don't
know but uh the many the plumbers I talk
to would hire an apprentice if they
could find somebody who was interested
in committing to a four-year training
program I mean that's the Big Apple
there is it's not a two week six-month
project it's a four-year commitment okay
thank you very much other questions
representative Brown and then go uh
thank you madam chair thanks for taking
my question so uh the the first one is
very simple can Apprentice ever be an
apprentice ever be alone at a
job I think that the uh licensing board
has been modifying the rules on that a
little bit it used to be that the rule
said that an apprentice had to be under
direct
supervision and the
defition modified somewhat I think to
anticip anticipate that you could be
supervised by
FaceTime uh which is a wonderful thing
that technology is great if an
apprentice runs into a problem and is
alone on a project hey boss look at this
tell me what to do with this maybe that
works but it doesn't install a lot of
confidence in the in the property owner
who's seeing this happen Okay and follow
up follow up with slightly different
question so you prefer a Ono one but you
said there are cases where there may be
a large project where it could be 15 to
one so each individual Apprentice can't
be very specifically watched in that
case is that accurate I think those
kinds of things happen on new
construction where you have a lot of
production going on and you have two
apprentices cutting pipes that are 10
feet long you know that's not too
difficult but when you have somebody out
in a truck doing service calls that's
another story and you couldn't really
have a licensed person with two or three
apprentices you know you go to a house
and you're going to show up with two or
three apprentices that's not where the
the model will
work thank you I'm sure that the
difference between a two-week apprentice
and a three and a half year Apprentice
is
significant correct representative
Manti Madam chair uh thank you for
taking my question you answered your own
question question in terms of 1: One
Versus
1:10 and there are it's un it's not
uniform correct Plumbing is not uniform
it's not all Individual Services um
services at a
home so my question to you is is it
better to keep the constraint of one to
one when there's a lot of housing needs
reconstruction renovation re building
when we need a lot of plumbers would
that help to expand this
apprenticeship concern over that is
having more inexperienced people doing
the work that's not really the answer we
want to have experienced people who know
the code and know the practices of
Plumbing rather than having a lot of uh
trainees and people learning If You're
Expecting someone to come to your house
and and fix something because you need
to have it fixed are you going to want
to have an experienced plumber or you
going to want to have somebody fresh off
the boat so to speak and and who doesn't
really understand what he's doing been
taught some things but not as
knowledgeable as the person who has the
license I I would like to say that if
there's a possibility of implementing a
rule that would govern the ratios on a
project I would be in favor of that that
uh I'm not in favor of trying to make
things more costly to the consumer or to
the to the Builder or whatnot but uh
there are other better ways I think to
get more labor into this uh field than
than there is by this uh Bill thank you
representative
Goldie thank you madam
chair speaking of plumbing and the
trades and all that
is heating systems in included in part
of the plumbing trade or not doing the
piping and everything for no uh heating
is referred to as mechanical we have a
mechanical licensing but the mechanical
licensing only licenses plumbers and gas
Fitters the gas Fitters are the ones who
can install gas fired
appliances but if it's not a gas fired
Appliance there's no licensing for
that a a oil burning Appliance has a
certification from the fire marshal but
that's it yes you have a
followup if you
have an inexperienced
person doing plumbing and they
don't understand the proper venting or
pitches to disperse of that stuff what
could
happen a lot of things can happen happen
sewer gas is a pretty dangerous thing
it's methane and it can poison us it can
also um cause um flammable situations I
would think um and you we're talking
about venting you were I think you might
have been referring to um uh combustion
gases being removed from the house
Plumbing venting is important two ways
uh Plumbing venting um maintains the
Trap seal so that we're not breathing
Vapors that are coming from the sewer
from our septic system the trap in that
water excuse me in that trap prevents
those gases from coming up and if the
venting isn't done
correctly then the um trap gets siphon
not much maybe just a little bit but
that's enough to let the gases come into
the
building thank you
followup that would be considered a
fairly important safety issue to make
sure that those are done correctly and
having an eye on that individual while
it's being done to protect the safety of
an
individual sorry was that a question I
would say yes it's important uh quite
important uh and that's um the reason
that that we do this extensive training
for such a long period of
time representative
simonk M thank you madam chair and thank
you for your testimony it's been very
helpful um just for clarification
purposes um within the context of the
conversation about whether or uh not you
want an inexperienced or an an
experienced person doing the work in the
apprenticeship model does the trainer
have to sign off on all of the work that
The Apprentice does check it before it
can be approved or is that a little bit
looser well I think you know The
Apprentice Works under the direction of
the
lensee so in some respects the Ling is
taking responsibility when an
inspect long um I would suppose LIC he
takes responsibility for it uh but he
can always blame The Apprentice as the
one who caused the problem but so
there's that that direct supervision if
you if you're trying to supervise five
plumbers to make sure all that's being
done five apprentices excuse me that
gets a little bit more challenging I
think anybody would admit that trying to
keep track of five three people as
opposed to one is is three times as hard
perhaps uh
followup so in in that case
um where an installation went wrong and
and something happened a backup or you
know some the home owner's unhappy maybe
wants to Sue and you know has a case uh
who would that um lawsuit potentially be
against would it be against the licensed
plumber Against The Apprentice who would
take responsibility in that situation
lawyer but I would imagine it would be
the company itself would be assumed some
liability but um there are also
complaints that the PLC can take for
unprofessional conduct and violating the
code
or list of uh of uh
um no NOS in the rules that the plumbers
are supposed to do and not do and they
can be held accountable whoever does the
work I suppose if it's if it's an
employee license who makes the error
then maybe that person can be complaint
a complaint can be driven on that person
for unprofessional conduct so there's
that side of it uh and then the Civil
side that's legal and I can't really
speak to that
thanks representative
Brown thank you Madame chair so it uh
there's obviously a difference between
as was said an initial apprentice and
someone that's been in until their last
month of their
apprenticeship somewhere along the line
is it accurate to say that a plumber
would allow that person to be on their
own as they following the licensing
board's
rules
okay all right representative thank
you representative
Sullivan thank you thank you Miss Mrs
chair um I yeah I come here I'm one of
the sponsors on the bill and I support
this bill
because I'm also from the North Country
I think most of the people who are on
this bill are from the North country and
I'll share a story when I back in I
don't know 2020 21 the sink my sink
broke in my kitchen the pipe snapped off
and so I called a plumber and this was
in I think it was September of that year
and they told me they get to me in
November so who can live without a sink
with a working in in for two months like
that's insane right fortunately I have
um I'm the only male in my family for my
grandfather on down who's not a plumber
and so I have a lot of people they don't
necessarily live close to me but I I
have a lot of people that I can you know
pull the family card with and have them
come help me in in these sorts of
essentially a crisis if you're if your
things not working
and I tapped into that when this bill
came up and I was like what do you guys
think about this and my brother who
lives here in New Hampshire he was like
yeah he's like I think three is probably
about the upper limit of what you would
want uh just because it would become
hard to manage them certainly on a job
site you know if you have a bunch of
them running around he goes but yeah
definitely we could have more than one
he goes it's it's most of the time I'll
spend time with a with a and he's a
master plumber he goes most of the time
I will spend oneon-one with somebody
initially in the early phase up of them
but then you kind of send them off and
then you go and check in on them and he
goes it it wouldn't be hard to manage
three he goes if you guys change it to
10 I think that would be a problem
because it would be really unmanageable
but three he thought was reasonable I
talked to my cousin who uh is also
plumber as I said all all the males my
family are plumbers I somehow missed it
and which is too bad because they make
so much money um but uh they he he's
like yeah he's like oh that's he's like
it's totally reasonable like he goes he
goes we benefit from a lot of the
regulations that we have in in the
plumbing industry that drives up the
cost of Plumbing because it does it does
keep down the cap of plumbers whether
it's the Apprentice program whether it's
the number of hours needed there's a lot
of regulations there that perhaps are
are overly conservative as as
representative King has suggested when
he was giving his testimony um but
another another point that when I was
talking to my brother in great detail
about this last week and he he said he
was yeah he's like you know one of the
good things that would be good about
this is if I could have three come on
because the problem is is is as as the
previous speaker said a lot of people
don't want to do trades right now so
they come in and then they do it for a
month or two and then they drop out and
then they have to start over he if I had
three and I have one or two drop out at
least I still have one who might make it
through the whole program it really
increases your odds and he said that's
where I think this matters the most most
he said the biggest problem is is if we
could only have one right now they they
often don't last more than a month or
two and they don't like that and I know
the plumber that I use I live I
represent Bethlehem and I own a property
in Littleton and I had the local plumber
there and I spoke to them about it and
when they heard that I have a lot of
family and plumbing they asked if I
wanted to become a plumber to work for
them and so I do think that there's a
problem with trying to recruit to the
previous gentleman who spoke I think
there's a big problem with with getting
kids today to want to do that that
that's just not easy to do and so I I I
really do appreciate that but if you
have two who are willing in that moment
it'd be great if you could take both of
them in that moment and I'm not sure
that that's going to happen often that
you could take two or three at a time
because I don't know that there's a you
know the supply of people who are
willing to do it but if that opportunity
presents and a good a high percentage of
them drop out it would be really
shameful to think that you know we we
only only could take one to have them
waste three months of time and then have
to start the whole process over again if
we really do want to increase the
pipeline what we need to do is give the
tool and the flexibility among these
these companies and again what's
important and I think this really
important to remember this this does not
require anybody to change the way
they're currently operating their
business but if you are somebody like my
brother who thinks having three would
not be a problem then they could do that
and then they could manage the three and
then when one or two of them drops out
we still have an extra plumber going
through the program and that benefits
all of us because as we all know at
least for me I think the biggest problem
facing the state is the shortage of
Housing and one of the reasons why we
have a shortage of housing is we don't
have enough people trained to build
houses and construct houses and we have
an aging state so a lot of the people in
the trade specifically are retiring and
there's not young bodies coming in to
sort of fill in the Gap so I really hope
that you guys take this cons this this
it's a pretty small change but I hope
that you guys really take it seriously I
really do think it has a potential to
you know move move the ball in the right
direction in terms of reducing the cost
of constructing houses and getting
people to to fix things when when they
break like my sink that would have taken
two months if I hadn't had connections
so um with that I'll take any
questions thank you represent man py
thank you madam chair you answered some
of that but I want to ask how are the
other neighboring states doing this have
you checked if it is one-on-one or uh
more than one Apprentice I know in
Vermont it's different so I texted my
cousin as I was sitting here waiting and
that's why I delayed my speaking because
I was hoping to to get back to me um so
I asked him he works in Massachusetts
not in New Hampshire um but I think you
can now work in both now I I believe but
uh he says that it was one Apprentice
per per plumber but he believes that
changed it this year and he was looking
into it and he hasn't gotten back to me
yet so I don't have that answer right
now sorry thank
you
followup thank you U Madam chair and
again the consumer at this point has the
choice I could ask for a plumber pay
exorbitant price for an
emergency
uh
visit if I have a sink leaking and if
that is not satisfactory as an consumer
I can say I don't want this coming back
or I can go back to a different one
isn't it so the choice for the consumer
like you had for two months but there is
choice right now to get whether you want
Master Plumber T you know or Apprentice
whatever no representative mapy that's
not correct right now you need to have a
licensed plumber performing work unless
you're doing it yourself and whether the
M whether the plumber is a master or
Journeymen is not relevant really but
they need to have a license or it's
illegal so that it's already covered
that they can't send an apprentice
without a license I know Apprentice has
a
license
okay thank
I think what this would do to sort of
address your question I think you I
think you could certainly let's say you
had a problem at your house and you you
had a plumber come and they sent an
apprentice who maybe wasn't as skillful
enough I think maybe this is getting to
the heart of your question I think you
could certainly reach back out to them I
think any like any business I I can't
imagine Plumbing would be any different
you could reach out to them and say
listen that guy did a really bad job and
I want you to come back and fix it and I
also don't want you to ever send him
again because I don't think he's skilled
enough I mean certainly you could have
that discussion but uh I I mean I think
one of the problems is is there just
isn't enough plumbers and so you know
you're going to be waiting a long time
in some cases particularly if it's not
an emergency or in my case even if it is
an emergency you might still have to
wait months um so oftentimes it takes
time to get an e emergency to be able to
to get things done and I could share
other stories from my apartment building
that I own and and uh it literally took
it to getting emergency point before
they can come and address it and so we
need to think about ways and I I
appreciate what the previous speaker
said about expanding trade programs and
opportunities and and that's one of the
many many levers we should be pulling to
try to increase the capacity of the
plumbing industry and in the trades
industry more broadly and but I I do
think that this is an important
important I don't think it would be
particularly uh dangerous for society to
have a little bit of
expansion okay thank you represenative
Vera
thank you so representative Sullivan are
you aware of a glut of apprentices and
they don't have plumbers or is it the
other way
around it's it's probably the other way
around um
but I think that kind of misses the
point of this bill though because if
there was a glut it would be Nob brainer
we should be doing this right but that
doesn't mean there aren't instances
where there maybe is a glut for a
specific town and they can't and so
people can't get in and we wouldn't want
to create that if that opportunity if
that does happen to create opportunities
for those kids to get into the program
or
people follow you I don't have a
followup thank you that answers my
question thank you all right Mr
Trombly
morning Madam chair committee members my
name is Bill Trombley I'm from
Manchester New Hampshire I um run or I
have run a family plumbing and uh
heating business for over 50 years I'm a
master plumber my master plumber license
is actually number one and um my father
actually started the uh Plumbing
licensing law way back in
1978 so I could talk about this subject
forever in in concept um I agree with
representative King's concept that we
need more plumber uh Plumbing Apprentice
the problem that I see that people don't
I don't think realize is New Hampshire
doesn't have a plumbing Apprentice
program so period we don't have a
plumbing Apprentice program New
Hampshire uses the federal government uh
Apprentice program the the Federal
Department of Labor not the New
Hampshire Department of Labor the
Federal Department of Labor so in the
rules and in the law it points over to
RSA 278 which is the um Apprentice
Council which we kind of all know it's
it's it's not really there and it's the
federal government so even if you pass
this law and you change this law it's
not going to make any effect because as
a company as a business owner when I
sign up an apprentice this I have to
sign an agreement with the Department of
Labor Federal Department of Labor that
I'll follow their rules okay and their
rules is one to one and this and it goes
on um uh past that so this is not going
to change anything because in order to
register as a plumbing Apprentice in the
state of New Hampshire you must first
register with with the state of with the
Department the Federal Department of
Labor first so it doesn't change
anything um unlike with the
electricians um the electricians do have
a state uh State of New Hampshire
Plumbing Apprentice program with an
electrician you can either sign up with
the Federal Department of Labor or you
don't have to sign up for the Department
of Labor uh basically what that means
for the electricians is if you're doing
a federal uh project if none if you are
not registered with the Department of
Labor you can't do a federal project
okay so for a small company like me
doesn't really matter but because I'm a
plumber I still have to do that so I
agree that there could be some work in
this area that could that could change
it that uh plumbers could have you know
two apprentices three apprentices not
quite sure I definitely agree with two
maybe three um um apprentices that that
should be out there and and answered so
just to answer some of the questions are
going on if you're a third year and a
fourth year Apprentice you're allowed to
work on your own as long as you have
supervision from your sponsor this is
the this is the term from the federal
government they just want um you to have
um supervision and their definition is
any electronic supervision or anything
else like that New Hampshire has
recently changed their rules in laws I
think is December of last year or
November of last year that a third year
and a fourth year Apprentice can work on
their own as long as they're um
supervised by a journeyman or a master
um talking about the gas license the gas
license you have to have direct
supervision all the time so you got to
also realize is the plumbing school is a
four-year Plumbing Apprentice realize
that we're getting more people signing
up for for the gas license than we are
Plumbing it's a one-year Plumbing a onee
um for gas Fitters versus four years for
plumbing so it's easier for somebody
coming out of school to go get their gas
license I'm not necessarily agreeing
with one year don't don't get me wrong
um um but uh but that's what we're
seeing when kids come out of the the the
the school um and I think there's could
be more work
like like Mr Evan said I was just we
were just notified that the Manchester
School of Technology they're plumbing
and electrical class um does not have a
teacher um for plumbing or or electrical
and it's tough to get a trades person in
there because I believe I'm not 100%
sure but you need a teaching certificate
to teach in that school it doesn't make
sense for somebody that is a plumber um
that you can't go in and teach Plumbing
that he doesn't they don't have a
teaching certificate I know that's
getting out of this committee's purview
but just to kind of let you know that's
that's what's going out there so in in
concept I believe that we should allow
more uh apprentices I'm just not quite
sure that by changing this this here in
this law will will'll do anything
because the plumbing program is a
federal program and with the federal
program the one the advantage of that is
we have portability is that if somebody
is in this program in other states and
they come to United come to New
Hampshire they can pick up where they
are where where they left off the truth
of that is probably um maybe I don't
know the exact number but there's not
every state is on the federal program
Massachusetts is on their own program um
Maine is on their own program I'm not
familiar with Vermont
um so immediate area um it doesn't do
too much but there are other states that
are on the federal program and they can
move from one state to another so I
think you have to come at it at a
different angle um if you want to change
the uh Plumbing Apprentice program uh uh
ratios so I'll happy to answer any
questions thank you representative Shu
thank you madam chair hello hello Mr
trle it's nice to see you again nice to
see you um would you agree that um a
master or journeyman plumber would
probably make more money on the job than
he would teaching and that might be a
reason that we have a shortage uh
probably but there's a you know there's
a lot of um good and bad things about
the the the work in is you might see me
walking in here I'm limping I need two
new knees and everything else like that
so um I I don't think somebody uh uh I I
would love to teach um you know some the
plumbing is in the blood so people
sometimes would like to teach and money
is not always the
answer it's thank you the questions
representative
Schmidt thank you madam
chair so it was briefly referenced
earlier by Mr Evans I think but isn't it
the case that new construction and o o
older homes or you know existing homes
two different worlds uh and and uh maybe
you could speak to the the the totally
different situation you have when you're
build building a new building a new
building yeah the great thing about
Plumbing is is that there's all kinds of
different as aspects of it you have the
service which is we're doing the repair
like repair in the sink you have new
construction um when you say new
construction you're you're building new
homes and stuff like that and then you
have commercial that is building these
commercial buildings around there
they're all different types of types of
work the thing is is with the with the
ratio is a company ratio so I have to
have one to one but if I'm on a job site
and I'm I'm a I'm a commercial um type
of plumber I could actually have five or
six apprentices with a j jman that's on
that job right now that's legal okay um
that works well for their situation the
problem is when it comes into the small
companies it's one to one now I'm
sending two guys out to fix a kitchen
sink and you know um you know exorb fees
you know they're not exuberant fees I
hate to say that because you're paying
for our education you're paying for our
knowledge I'm sending two technicians
out on this job and yes if he's a if
he's a first year Apprentice he's still
making pretty good money he's still
making 20 25 bucks an hour okay so um
and then my plumber is making well over
that so you know that's where the cost
goes up for the
residential um and I did utilize you
know or I do utilize the third and
fourth year yeah they should be able to
do something thir and first year you
know I was running jobs when I was when
I was a third and fourth year um they
should be able to replace toilets no
problem third and fourth year fix a
kitchen sink third or fourth year you
know those are things and I think we are
we did well when we got that rule
changed into December it hasn't got out
to the industry yet it just hasn't you
know the notification hasn't got out to
the in Industry so we haven't seen any
of that that effect on that yet yet but
um definitely I mean you know my good
friend Mr Evans and I may disagree but I
you know I would have no problem you
know having one to two maybe one to
three but um that would be a good start
but I think it's a major change in just
changing this
law all right thank you
the other
questions thank you for your testimony
no no I just have one for uh Mr if he
comes up he we will uh invite him to
speak next I
believe all
right does anyone else wish to
testify commissioner uh Mr Oster
house all right then we'll uh since we
have a question for Mr Oster
house
Douglas oer how
oplc Okay representative lus you have a
question we heard uh testimony that
uh that The Apprentice program for
plumbers is just under the federal and
that um you know even if we were to
change this to three it would have no
effect because there's a federal
one-on-one is is that your understanding
I would have to look at it more but it's
my understanding that
that we do have the ability as a state
to go above one to one but when we do
that we lose a lot of federal dollars we
lose grants we
lose the examples given to me were you
know there's grant money at the one to
one ratio where they'll buy equipment
for apprentices they'll boots belts
tools that kind of thing there's
education um money there if you're at
the one: one ratio and again as Bill
pointed out there's the uh you can't do
a federal job at one to one I I we could
go above one I
believe in rule right now if we wanted
to
but there that answers my question
there's
drawbacks uh I have a question could you
tell us how many plumbers there are in
the state and how many
apprentices I can get that number for
you thank you I think that would that
would be useful because if we're if the
problem is that we don't have enough
apprentices period then I'd be less
inclined to push this through then if
the problem is we don't have enough jobs
for the
apprentices although if the if the
problem is that all the apprentices
would rather live in the bright lights
of Manch Vegas than go up to Coos County
that's not a problem we can solve very
well anyone else repres
Brown M chair and thanks for taking my
question
um it would be possible I'm guessing if
we wanted to move forward with this to
make possibly
categories one to three and the first
two years they couldn't be left alone
for
example I think you could give the board
the ability to do that they they might
have that ability right now I have to
look at the statutes to see what their
rul making Authority is uh somebody else
may able to speak to that but
um well if if this number is only in the
rule and not in the statute then that
strongly implies it's within their
Authority would say I would hope so at
least yeah well you're talking about
categories though right to be clear to
be clear I'm saying we could say a a
plumber could have three apprentices but
the only ones that could be un
supervised directly would be year three
and four for
example it's already in there okay thank
you other
questions all right thank you very much
if you could also while you're looking
into the numbers report on what kind of
Grants we're getting and how much money
is
involved I
mean if it's a tool belt type of Grant
I'm not too worried about
it other
questions thank you very much we
yes what's
that clarify any of questions I'm
inviting everyone is there anyone who
wishes
yes
please I was just waiting for Doug to to
stand up to do
that how's that thank you Adam chair
committee uh my name is W young I work
for the US Department of Labor office of
apprenticeship uh I can answer some of
your
questions um the currently for plumbers
in the state of New Hampshire the uh
mechanical licensing board will not
issue an apprentice card without an
apprenticeship agreement from my office
to get an apprenticeship agreement for
my office you must be a registered
apprenticeship okay registered
apprenticeship is what we do previously
the state had been the registration
agency but now the federal government is
um to answer the question all of the
states around you in New England are
what we call State apprentiship agencies
we are the only office of apprentiship
or OA state in New
England um with that being said uh the
idea is is that the uh registrations
occur we provide the information to the
apprentice and the the sponsor of the
apprentiship of of the apprenticeship
sponsors are normally the companies that
that are involved sometimes they are
organizations uh such as the uh the
plumbers Union is an organization that
has a fairly significant program um but
this is why currently the plumbing
apprentices are at a 1:1 ratio because
that's based upon direction from the
office of apprentiship which is my
direction comes from the office of
apprentiship in Washington
DC oh so it's it's all your fault then
yes ma'am okay excellent glad to have
that that settled uh is there
any uh likelihood of that being changed
anytime time in the near
future currently the policy is is that a
sponsor May request a waiver from the
office of apprenticeship and so when I
say sponsor that would be the company or
the organization that has the
apprenticeship program can request a
waiver to change their
ratio uh there are a number of
requirements that they have to meet and
demonstrate to be able to do so some of
those things include their safety record
and their completion rate ratio for
apprentices
ah so that a company that has five
master plumbers and is currently doing
five apprenticeships could
ask if they had a good safety record and
actually their apprentices move on could
ask to go to 10 or 15 or 50 they could
they could ask for a higher ratio yes
they could that would be uh that there
is a process in place for that thank you
that's good good to know representative
mudy and then
Simon thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question is there in the
waer process is there any um special
consideration for undeserved or highly
shortage area um to get a
waiver the waiver is based primarily on
performance safety performance and
performance of the program itself
overall
uh the Department of Labor as you aware
of the US Department of Labor has a very
strong deia policy uh in support of
under repesentative uh communities so
that's it's not necessarily a part of
the discussion but it is in there it's
available thank you thank you anyone
else representative
Brown M thank you madam chair so is it
accurate what was said before that if
this bill were to pass it would be
irrelevant
if this bill passes and you're still
registering apprentices with my office
yes sir we'll still be at
one that's uh definitive any other
representative Simon thank you uh just
real briefly thank you for taking my
question in the waiver process in the
state of New Hampshire historically um
when people have received waivers what
has that ratio been has it just been one
to two has it ever been higher it
depends upon the
occupation Plumbing specifically so
Plumbing I have not seen any request for
waivers in plumbing from the state of
New Hampshire uh we do have a waiver in
effect for a different occupation and a
different company but I have not seen
any go through for
plumbers well that's
uh useful to know so that uh companies
could start ask asking for a waiver
tomorrow if they call my office I'll
give them the direction that they need
to help them thank you very much that's
good to know any other
questions all right thank you thank you
for your testimony and for the
information does anyone else wish to
testify all right seeing none we'll
close the hearing we are resuming at 130
p.m. excuse me at 1 p.m. my mistake
there's a commit and then a
commission
all right welcome back to Edna I'm
opening the public hearing on House Bill
1252 uh representative Gould are you
going to be presenting it representative
leus is going to present it excellent
thank
you
Madam chair
um this would establish a committee um
to look at a number of things um to get
you know input from uh Native American
communities in New Hampshire and others
and one of the big issues is
investigating um the possibility of
State recognition of the tribe um
abanaki have been uh recognized
officially in the state in Vermont not
in New Hampshire and there's a number of
reasons why this uh
matters there's a number of um me there
are tribes that are recognized by the
federal government and tribes recognized
by state governments the abanaki are
recognized uh currently by neither I
mean bermont but in New Hampshire uh
neither and there's a number of federal
laws that can be of benefit to the epan
AI who are citizens of our
state um you know one issue is um
you being able to sell crafts I think
they do basket work and other things um
as abanaki and there's a federal law
that if it's you're selling that and
it's not you're not a member of a
recognized tribe either by the state or
the federal government they're actually
really serious
fines um against doing it and uh my
understanding is there's uh that's
starting to actually be enforced and so
you have people who are you know Native
Americans abanaki they may uh produce
some traditional handicraft but they
can't legally sell
it there's a written testimony which I
think was just handed out um from uh
someone who provides more detail on that
than I
can so that's that um there's some other
laws for example there's uh um there's
federal law on things like migratory uh
b birds and other Wildlife where there
are specific exceptions in place for
recognized tribes I mean allowing them
to keep feathers from some birds that
would be illegal otherwise and some
other uh animal materials but unless
they're recognized either by the federal
government or by the state that they're
in um that that does not apply and they
can't take advantage of it and there's
some other federal laws having to do
with uh Native Americans that again um
only apply if the tribe is recognized
and the Authority for doing that
recognition um is explicitly with with
the the uh General Court the legislature
of the uh of the State of New Hampshire
so this is something that's appropriate
for a committee made of legislators to
look
into
um and
that's that's basically the point of the
bill and uh I'll try and answer any
questions but I think there are people
who will be able to you know provide
more detail on some of it than I'll be
able
to thank you representative leus I
believe you're
correct all
right uh christien oser Allen
Allen oh if they're together that's
fine
good
afternoon I'm mateline Wright I live in
Alton Bay New
Hampshire and I'm here today
representing the mount kirar Indian
museum in support of hb1
1252 I am a citizen of the nagan abanaki
tribe I was appointed by the governor
and served as a member of the New
Hampshire Commission on Native American
Affairs for one full term and am
currently a member of the mount kiraj
Indian museum Board of Trustees I would
like to
introduce my fellow trustee Kristen oer
Allen hello my name is Kristen oer Allen
I currently reside in BO New Hampshire I
am a member of the Pasa Madi Nation out
of Maine originally although I currently
reside here in New Hampshire now um I am
also on the Board of Trustees for Mount
kerage indiia
Museum the M kirar Indian museum
supports efforts to better understand
the needs and aspirations of Native
Americans in New Hampshire and
beyond our
hope is that
any is that any committee looking at
these matters would be allocated
adequate opportunities and resources to
complete a thorough and careful study
thank you very much for listening to us
today are there any questions for
anybody thank you
I no thank you very much very clear Tina
Daniels
hello good
afternoon um I am Tina Daniels and I
live in Goffstown and I am an enrolled
member of the Nel heagan coak nation of
Vermont
and I believe we need State recognition
because at this point all the
surrounding states in New England do
recognize their indigenous people
whether it's federal or state
recognition and New Hampshire stands
alone without that and I do support he
spill
1252 and because we have no official
state recognition it can be very hard to
get grants for cultural programs here in
New Hampshire and this is something
personally I've been having to do so we
go to Vermont to access the programs
that are happening there and they do run
a lot of
programs and because they can get the
art grants there much more easily and I
just came back from one two weeks ago
that was held for two days in
Burlington and they bring in instructors
from Indian instructors Native Americans
from other states to run those programs
for
us and I also want to say that I support
House Bill
1474 but I have another meeting in my
hometown this afternoon so I have to
leave for that thank you and oh are
there any questions thank you for your
testimony yes there are representing gr
then Brown then man py thank you so
could thank you um could you kindly tell
us about these art programs and what
their purposes are the purposes are to
to help bring back the culture that
we've
lost um for example the program I
attended two weeks ago two or three
weeks ago and it will be held again in
April in Vermont it's to help with um
weaving programs quill work which my
grandmother who was here in New Boston
and came from Quebec both my
grandparents they were big Weavers but
because they were actually born in the
late 1800s and I have her Loom but that
skill was never passed on to me so it's
Reawakening skills that were here but
had to be suppressed because it was not
considered it was certainly not
considered the thing to do I can just
tell you this my mother who was not
Indian worked for the State of New
Hampshire in the
70s and I was extremely firmly told to
never talk about it because she was
afraid of losing her state job at that
time I do have my grandmother's Loom and
so these programs that come in from out
of state are bringing back quill work
weaving Ceramics um anything related to
our culture that all it wasn't just
abanaki but all Northern Indians did
working with um
birch bark everything like that and in
fact there is another workshop in March
way up in cabat Vermont I'm going to and
that's what we can't access here easily
because I asked the person who started
the programs um Vera longtoe shean I
said why are all the programs in Vermont
because it's a long ways to drive and I
have to stay overnight and she said
because we can't get the grant access
easily in New Hampshire and she said so
so for this coming year 2024 they're all
going to be in
Vermont okay repr
Brown thank you madam chair um can you
expand a little bit on what um
representative Lea said when he
introduced this and we have a a piece of
information from uh a person in Bristol
who's in n heagan as well can you expand
a little bit on not being able to sell
products unless it's a recognized tribe
I don't personally understand that that
much because I've never tried to sell a
product but Sher Gould who is also a rep
is a jured member with the Le so she
could probably explain that
better yes thank you if she's going to
testify we'll do that rep Manti and then
Bailey thank you madam chair thank you
for taking my question I'm here
um I'm in Vermont do you know when this
law was passed and how they were able to
access these are federal grants I
believe I don't know that
answer I would H I can ask our chief
because he would he would
know I believe they achieved State
recognition I want to say around 2000
um six but I'm not sure okay thank you
if you could send us a note about that
we'd be very interested okay thank you
thank you other
questions don't see any thank you very
much
okay
up
good afternoon committee uh my name is
uh Paul pulio I'm The Saga or principal
speaker for the carar ban of panaco
ababi people we're headquartered and
located in Alton New Hampshire and I've
been a uh as you call a seated chief for
since
1990 hi my name is Denise pulio I'm the
head female speaker of the kaak band
located in Alton New Hampshire um I am
also the vice chair of the New Hampshire
Commission on Native American Affairs
I'm affiliate faculty um for the uh
Native American indigenous studies minor
over at UNH and I am also the president
of New Hampshire Public Health
Association thank you we come to you
today to oppose this not on its uh
principle of like it it has good
intentions but it seems to be quite
redundant and it's a it's a piece of
legislation that's looking for a problem
when in fact the commission of Native
American Affairs has already been
addressing all these issues and and
ongoing for the last few years and like
I think it was Peter Smith said we don't
need legislators looking at our problems
we can do that ourselves and come up
with some determinations and how to
solve these things what is uh not
obvious to all of you that a recognition
process is a very detailed uh process
that is going to cost money to the state
in all Canada if it's done properly
and it comes anywhere near the federal
process there's going to need be a need
for professional genealogists
professional historians and you can't
ask me to do that you need to hire
outside experts for this kind of work um
you can't expect us from inside the
community to um jury ourselves on these
issues you have to hire experts on that
it's going to if this goes forward with
any recognition process it's going to
cost the state cour quite a bit of money
um quite frankly we do a lot of
genealogy and it's running in excess of
thousands of dollars per family to prove
and vet U historical documents so just
be prepared for that as you go through
the process because people will be
submitting genealogy and you're going to
have to vet that through Professional
Services the other issue is the Arts and
Crafts act which comes up quite a bit as
a tribal leader for over 20 years we've
Tangled with u Bia on this issue and it
the original arts and crafts Act was
meant to be to protect certain Western
tribes and uh those that made silver and
blankets and things and they've they've
done a lot of overreach they've tried to
get into everything from Literature Like
if you've written a book and you say
you're AB neck you could be fine but
it's never been tested in court where
how far they can go of this we've
Tangled with them by saying that we are
descendants of the Penacook and they
have backed off from any litigation
against us and we also question the
sheer numbers of people you you're
trying to create legislation you don't
have enough facts in my opinion you
don't have enough facts about how many
actual oison and crafts people actually
being impacted by the OTS and crafts Act
and the Very fact that people have
Vermont status and they are a part of
Vermont tribes that's transferable to
here they can sell the RS and crafts
anywhere as long as they have that state
status so I don't understand the
duplicity of having to have a another
recognition in this state just to sell
crafts so in a nutshell I don't think
this bill is needed this time the
commission as you see in
1474 has been very prograph uh proactive
to trying to improve the way it operates
and these issues have already been come
up and we've already talked about how to
process this and how to deal with these
issues and to us um having legislators
play inside of our camp so to speak
speak is not necessary it's U it's just
a waste of uh taxpayer money and we
would recommend that you even table this
or put this aside unless the commission
can't act to to respond to these things
in the next year or so so with that
being said this is already on the agenda
arts and crafts although we don't have
vetted authority to prove anybody we can
we can BR we can bring up these subject
matters we don't have any authority to
recognize any but we can at least bring
it up and try to come up with a game
plan how to deal with that and that
would be my personal opinion from a
tribal leader now as a commission member
right um as a member of the New
Hampshire Commission on Native American
Affairs uh this bill was actually never
even uh proposed to the commission um
that we never received a copy of this
bill it was never brought up to us um as
a commission we're made up of um
community members as well as state
officials um that have positions within
the commission to give State oversight
and to give us access to State
resources um so adding another layer of
oversight to the commission um is just a
waste of taxpayer
money do we have any
questions don't see any thank you for oh
excuse me representative
gold thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my
question the commission did not um re
and vote to support it the Comm didn't
read this bill and votee to support it
um 1252 yes no they did not they did not
support this bill I guess I was
misinformed thank you yes um chair the
chair a an Jennison actually submitted
online testimony on behalf of the
commission thank you we'll have to study
that representative
maputi Madam chair um how many um
different tribes that exist in New
Hampshire do you have that
statistics um specifically abnaki or
intertribal tribes
or just in terms of the commission it
includes all of it correct um so the
commission is open to all residents um
who have indigenous descent here in New
who live here in New Hampshire um so
they don't necessarily represent a tribe
sometimes they just res represent um
their historical background as being
indigenous um we have Blackfoot Cherokee
and others that um currently serve on
the commission thank you tyo the list
goes
on okay you know by the way none of
those really would apply for recognition
nor with u arts and crafts if they have
arts and crafts uh permission they they
get that directly from their own tribal
uh communities thank you I don't see any
more
questions uh representative
Smith Madam chair do you require like a
DNA test before you prove you don't
really prove so you I could walk in
there and say I'm an abnaki and you
would accept that no absolutely not we
we deal with uh deep uh genealogical
research and you need vital records to
back that up we're finding that
ancestry.com is filled with a lot of U
false uh leads and uh you need to have
the backup you know Vital Records mean
birth death and and marriage sit
certificates and typically in uh the
abnaki culture it goes back all the way
to uh late
1500s and when we engage uh genealogists
you're talking in my case 15 generations
of research and if you just look at what
it costs to have a genealogist do
research on that uh they can only do for
$3,000 we've got quotes $33,000 only
five generations of detailed you know
analysis followup yeah yeah um I did
genealogy at The American Canadian
genealogy Society for quite a few years
and everybody that came in the door of
course they're can Canadian uh or
descent and they all said oh yeah my
Indian ancestor and you question them
and they said well I've got high
cheekbones so that you know enables me
to be a descendant of some Indian or
Native American um Mo I think 99% of the
people that say that are not and the
only way I can tell them to prove it is
to have a DNA test there is no DNA uh
database for New England tribes that of
of any substance uh this has been a
dilemma because uh archaeologically
we''ve always proposed you know any
human remains we find in Hampshire to do
DNA but other tribal groups strongly
oppose that because we've been trying to
do this scientifically to prove that
there was some kind of distin DNA strain
that would have been here in New England
uh every time we've ever found in Ur
remains which is very infrequent the
last one we found was in Freedom New
Hampshire and it was very very strong
opposition for us and we wanted to do a
tooth test which is one of the few
archaeological places where you can find
DNA and the date of the uh human remains
were probably what 2,000 years or 3,800
3,800 years it would have been great if
we could have done that but we had such
strong opposition to it so the DNA issue
is still a very strong one but it's not
precise and uh uh you know we we still
look at it as one of the tools but it's
not here at that point we could actually
use it we go back Vital Records uh in my
case I've got multiple multiple lines as
I do more and more digging but it's it's
you know if I had some old ancestors
that could do a DNA it would have been
great but I I just don't have them alive
anymore okay okay thank you okay
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on House Bill
1252 all right seeing none I will close
the public
hearing
car okay so we have a few minut minutes
uh we'll go into executive session uh
representative
grod yes madame chair I move OTP on this
bill I think that the com this
commission I mean this committee has
heard um testimony about this and I
think it's time that we look into it and
I think a study uh committee is an
appropriate way of doing that I don't
think that this is something that we
want to take lightly and uh I I hope
that the um committee will support the
OTP is there a second representative man
maner py do you wish to speak to your
second want to make a point about yes a
few years ago a senator in Vermont state
did introduce this and they have since
been able to access some of the
funds uh specifically for education and
expansion of uh the tribe skills in
including them in the larger Vermont
stuff so I with that I will say yes I'll
support
that anyone else want to represent laus
um just to address one concern that was
raised about potential cost of tribal
recognition I mean that's one thing for
the committee to look into the committee
can't obligate any money it would just
propose a legis a future
legislation yes I would have to agree
that they're not it's not in the scope
to to start the registration process
just to
say we think it might be
worthwhile any other
comments questions all right then the
motion is ought to pass by
representative gr and the clerk can call
the
role representative Simon yes
representative
leakas representative Bailey yes
representative Dolan yes
clerk vote Yes representative Boyd yes
representative
Brown
yes
representa representative
MCG yes representative Schmidt
no representative
goalie representative sht yes representa
Fitzpatrick
yes representative Gould yes
representative Smith yes representative
manui yes and the
chair
no 14 yay to
Nay
okay passes 14-2 is there any objection
to consent representative Schmidt
objects to consent okay we will not
we'll put this on the regular calendar
and I will say that my issue is that
this is not a study committee I would
want to serve on
so and that's
one yes
exactly all
right all right thank you you can
um
do it at your very earliest
convenience
okay all right thank you all and we'll
close the executive
session
y
okay I'm opening the hearing on House
Bill
1474 and I representative Schmidt you're
are you introducing
this are you introducing this you're the
prime
sponsor I'm the prime sponsor I think I
could be thank you I agree with
you
testing I hear you I think I think it's
in the system I don't think it's in this
microphone but something is a little bit
um wacky today with our sound system so
for the record representative Peter
Schmidt representing Dover Ward 1 which
is Stafford 14 um and um I'm pleased to
be before you today uh with regard to
House Bill
1474 relative to the commission on
Native American Affairs um and um
um one of the reasons I voted no on the
previous bill is well I won't go into
any great length on it it wouldn't be
appropriate but I think I think we we
already have a commission on in Native
American Affairs in this state um which
has been in existence for quite some
time but it but it also has had some
problems with regard to membership uh
and active participation in the in the
in the committee in the commission um
and so I think that we um we owe it to
our indigenous fellow
citizens uh to um look at this
situation uh with a um with a benevolent
eye not in terms of the great white
father um know overseeing the um the the
lives and and culture of our American
Native brothers and sisters but the the
reality is that we have an obligation as
as representatives to to look at the
commission and see whether it can be
improved um in in its involvement um it
already has a number of distinguished
people who who have served and are
serving um and I'm I'm not going to um
extemporize here on the subject because
uh this is something that where the
prime people who are giving evidence
should be people who are
indigenous they don't need anybody to
help them uh deal with their own Affairs
their own culture uh but the commission
is intended to further uh the progress
of indigenous people in this in this
state in this area and uh we should
strive to help them do as much as
possible so I won't take any questions
because we have indigenous people here
we should listen to
them thank you representative
sh Paul
pulo for rid uh good
afternoon uh
committee members commission members we
um ad admin board uh my name is Paul
poer I'm the suer for the kak band of
Penacook ABI people located in Alton and
again I've been a community leader for
since 1990 we are in uh support my my
particular position as a tribal leader
is to support 17
1474 for various reasons uh I have not
been on the commission since its
Inception but I've uh seen its struggles
uh since it was um first cified and the
issues you see in this uh drafted
legislation didn't come easy there was a
the commission met uh on quite a few of
the shortcomings and problems we' had
trying to maintain a quorum and
maintaining some continuity of of uh the
board and the commission itself and we
realized that there were certain things
that were originally uh legislated that
that were almost impossible to meet and
one of those criteria there was a
commission of um 15 people and uh
several of them are State uh positions
from the uh odds Council the tourism uh
Department of historical resources that
type of thing but we've always
maintained about a three uh vacancies uh
for reasons that are beyond the control
of our community or the
commission uh when you set up uh 50
um member uh commission and you have a
quorum of
nine you have to cut it back in half so
you start off of 15 and seven and a half
that becomes eight and then you need
plus one so it always was nine and it
made no sense because there was never a
full board ever uh seated so to speak
and uh it it that process continues uh
during covid the governor wasn't making
any uh appointments and it just got
worse throughout that whole time period
And as it stands right now there's still
three vacancies we know we know for a
fact that the department of historical
resources has put in recommendations to
fill these seats but it's stopped in the
governor's office so that was one of the
things that was going to be suggested
and that's what the commission did was
to bring it down to a simple majority of
those members that were seated plus one
so it's 50% of those the governor
appointed plus one as a quorum
standard in the hope of moving this
forward uh dmouth was always given a
seat on this commission but UNH wasn't
and that was one of the flash points we
saw from uh the fact that uh a Native
American um uh studies indigenous and
Native American studies U uh curriculum
was developed on un and is a minor now
on campus so so un should have been
included in any process with indigenous
Affairs so the proposal was to add one
one of those seats which is vacant make
sure it is from the University of New
Hampshire um there was also a concern to
not heavily stack this with one tribal
entity or another kind of like an
anti-nepotism type approach we don't
want everybody from one family so the
other thing we we felt was important is
to make it as robust as possible
with as much representation across all
the indigenous uh folks that are living
and resident in the state regardless of
your tribal affiliation it wasn't to be
an abnaki commission it was meant to be
a diverse State uh residency type of
thing so that was the other thing that
we brought up and the other issue was u
a lot of the original codification
rested on federal statute which truly
does not apply to a commission that
doesn't have any vetted of federal
priority to deal with um case in point
like child welfare cases we've handled
child welfare cases since the 1990s and
they come from all over they don't just
happen in New Hampshire they happen all
over the country when people get into a
child welfare case and we've been
consulted on um probably a couple of
dozen over the since 1990 and it it's a
it's really a relationship from a
community to that agency it's dealing
the Child Welfare case and it's not a
commit issue just like the Arts and
Crafts thing we never really had an
issue with arts and crafts in our
particular tribe because we pushed back
we push back on that threshold because
it's meant that we weren't competing
with other abnaki we identified
ourselves as Penacook right here in New
Hampshire as Penacook we're not
competing with some tribe in the in the
west that's making silver or or braided
rugs and we didn't see the same issue
because we didn't have the demographic
Graphics that supported any legislation
that dealt with just the the Arts and
Crafts act beyond that it was a cleanup
and this wasn't a shallow effort this
went through Ben Wilson which is the U
the state shipo who also is sits over
the commissioner of Native American
Affairs was reviewed with him and found
out anything that he felt needed to be
done and I know the commission brought
in the AG's representative the the
commission has uh a permanent uh AG
representative that attends the meetings
now and these issues were brought up
with the AG's representative and they
went through the word smithing to make
sure nothing was out of order and that
everything was above board as it was
presented and what you're looking at is
the result of the combined effort of the
commission outside Community leaders uh
the department of historical resources
and obviously the AG's department so
with that being said um this is really
just to update the commission it's more
of a uh a maintenance issue uh it does
have an element in here where we can
assist on providing educational
resources because us as a uh a
non-federal tribe but we also are a
federal uh nonprofit indigenous group we
are eligible for all kinds of Grants
from the federal government in fact our
tribe has gained significant amounts of
federal money directly without the
Federalist State status it's because uh
they also recognize Native American
nonprofits is a a potential uh grante
for Grants so uh with that being in mind
we strengthen the program thing about uh
history culture Affairs and Dei uh
developing educational materials as part
of uh the acts that were established by
the federal government beyond that the
rest of the issues that are federal they
were removed uh out of the Shia fact
that we're not commission was never
vetted for that so with that being said
do you want to speak for the commission
you pretty much said it all and I'm not
going to waste their time repeating so
um thank you thank you we'll record your
support any
questions represent
goie thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking my question uh page
two line 25 can you tell me why that
section has struck out
it's not on
ours could you uh start the line because
it doesn't match with any cross out on
page it's the very last
line
okay okay the authority um The Authority
for U that Authority is really uh a
legislative Authority that's not a
commission Authority and all Canada see
I triy is pursuing Federal
acknowledgement and being very candid we
petitioned in the 1990s we are on record
with the federal government we're going
through the federal process which is
more in detail it's more in depth we
have to show continued governance we
have to show genealogical revance we
have to also show historical re
relevance um so I don't think this could
be something vetted into the
commission's authority to do the
commission doesn't have the legal
authority to recognize or deny a tribe
that's left up to the state legislature
so so why are you striking the line that
says it's the legislator's respon
legislator's
responsibility you don't you don't have
a process do you right that so the um
that line was struck um I was told
because New Hampshire does not have a
state recognized
tribe and so the Arts and Crafts act
does not apply um the arts and craft act
follows um the recognition based on the
tribe and where they are located so you
could be a recognized Tribal member of
the Cherokee and um out of Oklahoma live
here in New Hampshire you can still sell
your arts and crafts as native Ma you
don't have to be recognized by the state
of New Hampshire as um as indigenous
that recognition follows you throughout
wherever you happen to live thank you
that any other questions represent
representative Schmidt you can't ask any
questions representative maputi thank
you madam I'm a little confused the
previous bill was doing just that to
recognize the state commission or uh the
tribal I mean relative to to study the
needs of Native Americans in New
Hampshire one of the studies was to
establish recognition of different
tribes in New Hampshire isn't that the
bill actually states that that it's
establishing a study group of the in
needs of indigenous people of New
Hampshire it actually doesn't state that
it's going to establish a recognition
process that was just a proposal that
was put out by the
representative thank you we don't need
to discuss House Bill 1252
anymore but uh thank you for any other
questions about House Bill 1474
representative Brown M sherff uh thank
you again taking our questions
um uh again on on the last page
uh item three in the commission's duties
has been stricken but it seems like we
did talk about that to some degree in
the last bill
and why why would that be a good thing
to take
out um the New Hampshire native
commission does not have the legal
authority to dictate who can and cannot
sell indigenous crafts within the state
that's covered under a federal
law so um the commission doesn't have
any right to fulfill that that call ah
okay thank
you all right thank you very
much anyone else I don't see
any all right thank you all
right turn the mic on please I'm sorry I
want to add one more thing um uh
Franklin Pierce law the University of
New Hampshire law school has now started
a title 25 law course which is a course
that teaches about indigenous law um
which includes the Arts and Crafts act
that you're all debating today um so I
would highly recommend you reach out to
UNH law and speak to the professor there
thank
you anyone else wish to testify on House
Bill
1474 seeing none I will will close the
public hearing and open the executive
session does someone have a motion
representative
gold mam chair I'd like to move inim
study for this bill so that the uh study
committee can take a look at it and see
where it fits with the broader findings
they come up with especially on the
issue of State
recognition is there a second
seeing representative Bailey seconds all
right uh represent baile do you wish to
speak to your
second okay any discussion comments
questions anyone else I'm sorry so is
the um the idea of the interim study to
make House Bill
1474 part of the responsibility
of the committee inhouse Bill
1252 represent gold is that your intent
that was my thought yes that that
there's some overlapping areas here and
that um the study committee could take a
good look at how to best come out
there's strengths in this petition for
sure but how do how does that fit in the
broader recognition piece that
everybody's had good questions
about can I comment on that okay so I'm
not not convinced of that because one of
the things that one of the components
that I like about
1474 is that it establishes
um the Quorum and it establishes the
limitation of One Tribe for
representation so I think that those
types of things are important the only
thing that concerns me is the strikeout
on page two on lines 25 and 27 so if um
I would like to investigate that and
confirm that before we move on to this
bill because I don't see an issue with
it okay um
I I'd like to say that I'm also not in
favor of interim study because the
issues of reorganizing the commission
getting its Quorum fixed is and and
simplifying
it duties and responsibilities is very
important
uh Mike I don't know about the deletion
since everyone admits that is a
legislative
responsibility so the question is do
they do they need that statement in
their the definition of the commission
or not and if the chair will allow me I
would certainly look into that unless
representative Schmidt knows the answer
cuz he just raised his hand
representative Schmidt do you have the
answer to that I didn't hear the
question the question is whether
the excuse me the the deletion of the
statement of legislative responsibility
is because it doesn't fit in with the
definition of the commission and not an
attempt to redefine whose responsibility
it
is thank you for your question I can't
get a give a definitive answer um but I
and I did not ask for any of this
language to be struck um uh because uh I
I'm not setting myself up as some kind
of an authority on any of this matter
this is something that the indigenous
people of New Hampshire should be uh
tasked with and and I especially think
it's uh inappropriate to go to indrum
study one of the major uh purposes of of
this bill is to improve the
functionality of the commission by
changing the quorum to a workable
situation which is not currently the
case so to the degree that we take away
its primary function we're neutering the
very thing that that uh needs most to be
taken up and to be acted on thank you
thank you all right represent
goalie thank you madam chair and being
the one to bring up that subject of the
struckout language I too would like
further clarification to make sure it is
what it is and if at all an amendment is
done I would also probably once again
ask because as you proof this if you
look on line 20 once again OLS is just
semantics with wording again making a
change that really isn't necessary
meeting notices of all meetings and
changing that wording is totally
unnecessary and I don't know why they're
doing what they're doing okay um if it's
the pleasure of the commission of the
committee rather we
will defer the vote on this bill until
the previously scheduled executive
session on the
13th okay so we will postpone this while
we're looking into those specific issues
thank you madam chair that's an
excellent proposal all right
you all right
and house bill
1174 does someone have a
motion sorry what is 11 pling a
parenthesis Madam chair I have a motion
yes expedient to
legislate okay is there a second all
right the motion is inexpedient to
legislate by representative Gould second
by representative goalie would you like
to speak to your
motion Madam chair I just want to
clarify we're talking about 1435 no no
no we haven't gotten there yet I
apologize this is House Bill
1174 the plumbing apprentices we heard
this morning oh oh oh oh oh can I
withdraw my motion I was I'll I'll make
a motion of itl and House Bill 11 all
right it's by represent gr seconded by
representative goalie okay thank you
glad she admitted the confusion before
she tried to explain it so represent gr
you have a comment I do
um although I sympathize with um
individuals who seek um apprentices
apprenticeships and can't find them
there seems to be an existing way of
having waivers for um having um more
than one Apprentice per plumber and I
don't see this bill as solving any
issues that are um apparent in New
Hampshire so I don't think that we need
this bill
okay representative
goalie thank you madam chair and I to um
believe in the testimony that was given
to us that this is due to the federal
regulations that we follow by
apprenticeship um one onone is what they
require um but there is a waiver
available that it seems like not too
many people out there really know about
and listening to the individual I don't
think they've received any requests for
waivers um so in my discussion
afterwards with the commissioner of
Labor about getting this word out there
to these organizations that is their
intent to make this known and I think
that's probably the appropriate thing to
do knowing that they're more than
willing to Grant the waivers out there
and I don't think having
apprenticeship increasing the number of
apprentices per plumber is the problem I
think the problem is getting people to
apply for
apprenticeship and I think that's the
bigger problem that we need to look at
maybe address in trade schools and else
thank you represent man you had a
comment I I do agree that there is a pro
I mean the process that is existing that
is not known to even the experienced uh
plumber so is there a way to make that
known or available is it only through
legislation or is there a Ru making one
where they need to know that the Federal
grant is not going to be taken away by
applying for the waiver and I think
that's the key point that I took away
from uh hearing the testimony making
that waer program available in New
Hampshire can increase the pipeline can
increase
the if even if five
plumbers take up the waer and they
individually do two that's increasing
The Apprentice at a very grassroot level
so I just want to know uh if that is
some way
indicated way to be indicated without
the legislation um no we will put the
com comment that the waiver is available
in the committee report please because
that is important and other than that we
are re the commissioner of Labor who is
responsible for apprenticeship programs
will has said he will attempt to spread
the knowledge so pass the word to every
plumber you meet that's the only thing I
can say just a follow-up question for
that Madam chair so um will the
legislation be able to get a report or
whether or will we get a feedback saying
that way was went out or not or that's
not a preview that's not really our
issue the there is a similar Senate bill
that is on our way and we you can
consider adding it to that if you you
feel it's important representative leus
and then sh
it I mean I strongly support the goal of
this bill I'll regretfully support the
itl um partly the issue is uh you know
the complications the federal rules I
certainly hope that representative
goalie's effort to get the word out
succeed and that uh I agree that we also
whatever happens with this we need to
get more people in The Apprentice
program okay represent
Simon thank you madam chair um I also
will be supporting the itl in its
current form um I just wanted to add for
the record um I did have a conversation
with uh one of the gentlemen who uh gave
testimony who said that although he was
aware of the apprentic pro program at
the federal level it seemed better
suited for for larger companies with
more people um and would be pretty
onerous probably for a small in
independent um plumber in Northern New
Hampshire uh to access so it it is it
does exist um but it might not be a
great vehicle for everybody um but even
still it seems like there are steps that
would have to take place in the state of
New Hampshire um before something like
this could be brought forward uh maybe
more in line with something that the
Electrical uh apprenticeship program
which has access both to the federal
program if they want the federal program
or to State program because there is a
state program that does I believe allow
them to have two two apprentices at the
same time so but uh not having that in
place at the moment it would be
difficult to use this as a vehicle to
get to the to the end goal I spoke with
Senator bery at lunch and he tells me
that the
um the his similar Senate bill is being
amended to make the federal registration
optional rather than required which
makes a lot of sense for the smaller
businesses and I think that is the
proper vehicle to address it rather than
having an ident two similar Bills going
through and representative Shu you had a
Qui uh in addition to um this waiver
program that needs recognition we heard
during the uh testimony uh even by the
two
sponsors uh kept referring to rules
and the different levels of
apprenticeship that allow uh apprentices
to practice more independently and I
think that that particular issue is more
properly addressed in rules rather than
this bill so I will also support itl
yeah I was kind of upset that the
sponsor wasn't aware that there are ways
to change the rules without requiring
legislation represent Senator Brown you
have a question or a comment I just have
a comment so I I'm thank you madam chair
I'm I'm very much in support of this
idea as representative Lea said um and
from what you just said your discussion
with the senator I think that uh that
helps me to make my decision for
itl what I will add is though it we all
seem to very simply say well you can
just go get a federal waiver well who
knows how complicated that is it's hard
enough to get a special exception in a
small town planning board unless to go
to the federal government and get a
waiver on anything so I don't want us to
sort of be Cavalier about saying you
could have just gotten a waiver from the
federal government it may not be such a
simple
thing indeed no question about that
representative Schmidt and then
gold mam chair uh well I will also be
supporting the itl but your your remark
representative Brown and the fact that
the the federal official who was here
before us said that they had not had any
applications for waivers certainly does
not demonstrate that that it's difficult
to get a waiver it's especially
difficult to get a waiver if you don't
ask for one um but the the the point is
that um that we heard from the two
master plumbers who've been in in this
profession for
decades that one of the problems they
have is not that they can't get that
they can't have more than uh more than
one uh Apprentice the problem is they
can't get enough people to apply to
learn Plumbing period one of them held
up the cell phone he said this is what
the kids today want to be involved with
they want to be involved with the the
not just cell phones but modern
technology and they one of them
testified also that plumbing is a dirty
business you're dealing with human waste
uh and it it's one thing if you're
building a new building and putting in
toilets and and piping that's never seen
any content uh it's another thing if
you're coming into my house or anybody
else's house that's been in exist my
house for over a hundred
years it Plumbing has been there for a
long long time and it's still functional
but it's not nice when it has to be
worked on so that's the reality so we're
going in the right direction by it
alling the bill and trying to get people
to be better informed about their
options okay any other
comments represent gold yes thank you uh
Madam chair thank you now that I'm on
the right bill I agree with everything
everybody said I especially uh would
like to see some I wish that we had a
way to follow up and I like what
representative Simon was talking about
regarding the smaller um businesses
having difficulty dealing with the
federal but that probably goes beyond
the purview of our time but I'll support
the
itl all right thank you anyone else okay
the motion is inexpedient to legislate
on House Bill for 1174 and the clerk can
call the
role representative Simon yes
representative Lakers yes representative
Bailey
yes clerk votes yes representative Boyd
yes representative Brown yes
representative Gro yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative Shu yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative
G yes representative Smith yes
representative
manuti yes
and chair
yes we have 15 y0
n the bill passes 15 to zero is there
any objection to
consent you said the bill passes or did
I mishar
you
motion yes that was what I meant and
thank you for pointing out that I didn't
say what I meant the motion of itl
passes 15 to Z thank you
any objection to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
this on consent we W and I trust the
committee will keep track of their
concerns and issues so that we can deal
with them in the Senate Bill all right
and I will I didn't mean to correct you
madam
chair you and I correct we all know what
you meant the thing is that the record
would be misleading if we didn't if you
didn't correct it so thank you exactly
all right I will close the executive
session open the hearing on House Bill
1335 is representative Wen here well
there she is okay
yes
name
ice can you hear me okay yes for the
record I'm Amanda Bolen I represent
Hillsboro District 25 in
Manchester um one of my favorite books
is the Diaries of Adam and Eve um by
Mark Twain obviously Adam and Eve didn't
keep Diaries or if they did they haven't
survived today the book is hilarious and
a pretty short read you can find it
online um because it's so old Adam
complains about a creature that won't
stop talking um Eve complains that Adam
is aloof when they conceive a child they
debate whether it's a fish or a wild cat
Adam insists on proving it's a fish by
putting it in the water obviously it's a
human baby it's good read all around and
a solid example of a category of
literature known as historical fiction
or romantic
biography um it was the night before
Christmas and all through the house not
a creature was stirring not even a mouse
you all know that poem um it's called a
visit from St Nicholas the author was
Clement Mark Moore Clement Clark Moore
um and it was published in 1823 one of
my favorites I think I have the whole
thing
memorized and it was in this 1823 poem
that more invented the reindeer and name
them but do you recall the most famous
reindeer of all Rudolph wasn't part of
the Santa Claus franchise until 1939
contributed by another
author so you all know that Santa Claus
is based on St Nicholas a Catholic saint
he was alive around 300 ad he was a
Greek of Greek descent and lived most of
his life in what is now modern day
Turkey during his lifetime he became a
Catholic bishop he was very charitable
but to avoid embarrassing the recipients
of his kindness he left goods and
necessary items for them in the cover of
night and obviously this Catholic bishop
didn't have any flying reindeer uh yes
represent B don't worry if you could uh
focus a little more closely on the bill
at hand okay
um so a book that is uh the origin of
many of these aspects of Santa Claus was
written by an author named Washington
Irving and in his life Washington Irving
also wrote other literature that was
historical
fiction I know you've heard this bill a
lot chairwoman um I I don't know if
Groundhog Day is another holiday isn't
it um so I don't know how many on the
committee are familiar with the issue I
just thought I it okay um so another
work of historical fiction or romantic
biography is um called the uh hold on I
have to find it on my
screen so Washington Irving wrote an a
biography of sorts of Christopher
Columbus that in its time was criticized
as an attempt to annihilate American
history and this book is the origin of
the claims that Christopher Columbus
believed that the world was round when
everyone thought it was FL
um the origin of claims that he
discovered new land that had already
been discovered at least a thousand
years prior by a variety of other
explorers um and so so much of what
makes Christopher Columbus this historic
character is historical fiction um by an
author known for creating other works of
historical fiction in a time period
where it was culturally popular to
consume historical fiction but
unfortunately a couple Generations later
there was strong anti-italian sentiment
and anti-immigrant sentiment in the US
as it persists today um toward other
groups and in that vein those folks who
grew up with historical literature and I
assume didn't understand what they were
reading was fiction um invented a
holiday to help with the uh public
perception of
Italians
um so in reality uh Christopher Columbus
thought that the world was pear-shaped
in a time when everyone knew that it was
round and you could buy globes for sale
and and he was so adamant that it was
pearshaped because he was looking for a
shorter trip to India for spices and
Native Americans are referred to still
today as Indians because to the day he
died Christopher Columbus was convinced
he had found a shorter route to India
through the curve in the pair shape of
the planet um so instead of a flat
earther he's more of a par earther and
um he never touched American
soil um the closest he got was Puerto
Rico which was only um made part of this
country years after Columbus Day was
instituted
um and when he was on that land and he
encountered natives he rode them for
transportation if um he felt that they
were dishonest he would cut off their
hands um he sent them to find gold for
him in the
rivers and if they didn't produce enough
he'd kill them and in the time that he
was on a particular piece of land
he reduced a population from a quarter
of a million down to a couple hundred
people and in his time his activities
were regarded as criminal eventually
Spain sent the Spanish Monarch sent a
ship um to collect him and he spent a
substantial amount of time in prison in
Spain for his activities in the New
World in India um so the fact that today
in 2024 there are still people who
wholeheartedly believe these fictional
aspects
of this character a character not unlike
Santa Claus not unlike the Diaries of
Adam and Eve where that is not who they
were it's just how this author has
represented them the fact that these
myths survive today I think really
underscores the fact that the
Contemporary critic was correct when
they reviewed washingon Irvington
Washington Irving's biography of
Columbus biography and said that it was
an attempt to annihilate the history of
America um so about the bill it leads
columus day that's all thank you that's
a good I like history so I like
exploring it um and it should be noted
there are other aspects things that we
traditionally believe that are not
factual Paul Rivier didn't ever say The
British are coming yes thank you because
he was
British he would have said the regulars
are coming thank you other there any
questions seeing
none representative
Porcelli
afternoon everyone thank you for
allowing me to testify for the record my
name is Susan M pelli I am a
representative from Rockingham District
19 Hampton Falls in Kensington I strong
I am in strong opposition to this bill
as a proud Italian American I celebrate
the contributions of Italian Americans
that built this
country my
grandparents immigrated legally from
Italy in the turn of the
19th at the beginning of the
1900s my grandparents worked tirelessly
one grandparent helped build the Holland
Tunnel and they worked very hard and
they were very proud people during World
War II my the town I grew up in would
have the residents would have starved if
it wasn't for my grandparents and the
skills that they brought with gardening
and being able to raise livestock and
feed half the town during the Depression
in the early part of the
war my parents gave me a work ethic and
understood the Italian American
experience we worked very
hard growing up and into my early uh
career in business I experienced
Prejudice
discrimination and other horrible things
we were discriminated against in housing
I was discriminated against in the
workplace I still remember to this day
as a young woman in her 20s when I was
trying to climb the corporate ladder and
I had all of the credentials that
everyone else had and my manager said to
me we're not promoting you because
you're only an Italian
girl to this day that still res Ates
with me Italian Americans have
contributed to this country however
discrimination still
exists and I'm sure the other testimony
will be of the others will be able to
tell you about the atrocities that
Italian Americans suffered through in
the late
1800s the worst lynching of a group of
people in American history
Columbus Day to me represents a day to
honor the great contributions of Italian
Americans that built this
country and not to honor one specific
person Italian Americans are a proud
people a warm people a loving people and
the holiday is in that
Spirit italian-americans built this
country and we want want to be able to
recognize their contributions on this
one day it's not about the man it's
about the contributions of this great
warm loving group of people and other
immigrants that we celebrate together
and understand that America is the
greatest Melting Pot and best country in
the world that's why so many italian
Americans wanted to immigrate here so uh
I strongly oppose this bill any
questions thank
you think you've made your oh
representative G has a
question uh I I'm just wondering how
that Italian girl got where she is
today I you I kept working I outworked
everyone I proved myself every single
day and I still do that to this day and
it's because of the work ethic that my
parents inculcated in me
thank you this looks like it's going to
be a long hearing so let's try to keep
the questions focused representative
dallesandro excuse me Senator
dallesandro my
mistake uh thank you madam chairman uh
for the the record I'm Senator lud
alesandro I represent District 20 BS
Awards 2 3 4 10 11 and 12 and I um am
honored to come before you today in
opposition to this piece of
legislation I am an Italian
American my grandparents immigrated to
this country looking for a better
life uh they were
successful uh and in this context
they loved
America they were sled links in support
of the American dream which all of us
share it it gave to this country I far
far it far exceeded what they
received the the honoring of Italian
Americans is is something
that President of the United
States created colb day in order of of a
group of
Italians who were who
were un unly hung in in uh
Louisiana they were accused of a crime
they were all
acquitted they were taken out of they
weren't released from jail they were
taken out of their cells and they were
hanged no one has ever been accused of
the crime no one has ever been convicted
of of the crime
but this honor Columbus Day was to honor
these Italian
Americans and and to give response to
discrimination that existed against
these Italian
Americans and that's not to say that
others are not discriminated against
because they are but something like
this manifests that the country
understands that we're all in this
together Italian Americans Greek
Americans Irish Americans were all in
this together and this day Columbus Day
we
celebrate eth ethnicity but we celebrate
for everyone we could never lose sight
of that
fact I have been in these legislative
halls for the last 50
years I've seen discrimination against
myself and I've lived with it I've also
seen the wonderful companionship the
wonderful consistency in getting things
done together which makes a lot of sense
to me and indeed we should continue that
and discrimination against any ethnic
group has to be put put aside thrown
away maintaining Columbus Day is
important it's important because we
recognize the contribution of Italian
Americans but in essence we represent
the contribution of every ethnic group
group uh to this
country this country is built upon
bringing people together and we've got
to do more of that we've got to do more
of that as we speak today you know the
countryes in disarray we've got to bring
the country back uh to where it to where
it was so I thank all of you for your
attention I appreciate the opportunity
to appear before you uh and indeed I'll
ask it or address it question question
that you might have I apologize that I'm
going to have to leave because we're in
session across the street and uh we're
trying to bring good things to New
Hampshire so thank all of you for your
service a great American group thank you
okay thank you I represent
goalie thank you madam chair and thank
you senator for taking my question I
agree with your remarks um one quick
question this bill strikes Columbus
State as a state
holiday what would happen to those state
employee contracts that recognize that
in the contract as a state holiday
that's a very good question thank you
representative goalie it's a negotiated
item it will remade as part of the
negotiations and they'll renegotiate as
as we move forward but it's there and
please the lord it's going to stay there
and it will be not only Columbus Day but
it will be a celebration of ethnicity
and the pride that we all share in our
ethnic
Heritage thank you other questions don't
seeing none thank you Bab so much all
right
and we've got uh eight people with
Italian family names who wish to speak
against the bill all of them wanting
five minutes so I hope you will be uh
respectful of our time uh Francesca Mar
Marone
I hope
so um good afternoon um I was not going
to Franchesca Marone um from Portsmouth
New Hampshire um I was not going to
speak today but I was compelled after
hearing others speak uh my grandparents
immigrated to America in 1911 my dad was
a World War II decorated veteran
who always told us kids the greatest
gift that his parents ever gave him was
being born in America and we were to
never forget that um our cultureal
Italian culture culture is being ripped
apart what I believe is a knee-jerk
reaction of legislative bodies
Nationwide um let us celebrate our
heritage share our culture with other
peoples let us be recognized alongside
everyone else as Senator um Lou delandro
said Columbus Day is a symbol that we
use to celebrate our herit heritage and
our contributions to America um I
strongly oppose this bill and I say Let
It Be leave it thank you thank
you questions don't see any Thomas
rogi
hello and thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak in front of you uh
my name is Thomas Rossy and uh I'm a
relatively recent Resident of New
Hampshire having lived here for about 10
years uh my family also immigrated to
this country in the late 1800s and early
1900s and have fought for this country
in World War II the Korean War the
Vietnam War uh and have made many
contributions both in terms of helping
to build the country to build major
structures and do Labor uh in the New
York area as well as New Jersey and also
in the scientific Community it has been
their dream uh and my family's dream
ever since coming to these Shores to
pursue the American dream and with hard
work uh and perseverance and passing on
that desire from generation to
generation they made that dream a
reality uh for me and I hope to make it
a reality for my children uh as far as
Columbus Day is concerned I recognize
and acknowledge that there's a great
deal of Mythology about historic events
that occurred and were taught to us the
way they were uh in the 1960s and in
that era however uh Columbus Day to me
is more of a cultural sign significance
than a
historical uh recognition of Christopher
Columbus it's much more some recognition
of the contributions that people like
those in my family and many other
italian-americans such as those who
helped to build Portsmouth and resided
in the North End of Portsmouth for many
years until urban renewal uh decided uh
to really devastate the North End where
most of the italian-americans lived uh
they were erased from that Community
dispersed their housing was destroyed uh
and today it's simply an area where
large developers come in and uh profit
off of those lands so I don't want to
see the Italian American Community
further erased from New Hampshire uh by
eliminating the recognition of a very
cultural uh culturally significant day
for my people thank you very much thank
you and my apologize for mangling your
name that's no problem at
all okay don't see any questions Gino
Marone turn your microphone on please Mr
Marone thank you it was already on ah
um uh good afternoon Madam chair members
of the committee uh for the record my
name is G Marone and I would like to
preface that by saying I am here today
as private
citizen uh some of you I've sat before
in other legislative hearings um has
been has been what has been said is true
by every one who spoke before me uh this
is
personal uh we are we are a culture but
part of that culture personally is my
grandmother came over she was with child
when the child was born they named him
Columbus John Marone because he was on
the boat but the John partt actually was
for
Giovani gabato who English call him John
cett he was an Italian uh
Navigator uh and as a merchant Mariner I
know a little bit about that uh he was
Italian uh uh explorer who was credited
with this covering what we now know
today is Canada so there's a lot of
personal history here a lot of culture
and I will leave you with one last thing
and that is my good friend Senator delis
Sandro a few months ago wrote a great
oped in the newspaper talking about all
the accomplishments and contributions
that the Italian Community has made to
this state and to this country um it was
well worth the read so I won't take any
more time there other speakers thank you
thank you
okay Elis
Gallow short one copy so I'll leave this
when I leave thank you my name is Alise
Gallow I am an American citizen of 100%
Italian descent and I strongly oppose
New Hampshire State House Bill
1335 along with any similar veiled
attempts to discontinue our state
celebration of Columbus Day in fact I'm
urging the legislature to table this
bill indefinitely so we never have to
come here again to convince you of the
importance of the one and only American
holiday that honors the Italian culture
and my native people's contributions to
the state and to the country at large
I've lived in New Hampshire for 40 years
raised my two children in Brentwood and
served as an elected officer in that
Community from 2003 to
2016 I am now a resident of Portsmouth
in Ward 5 October last year I took the
Portsmouth City Council to task for
their shameful abolishment of Columbus
Day and replacement of it with
indigenous people's day at the request
of a group of misinformed middle school
children as if it makes any sense to
replace the Americans of Italian descent
with Americans of Native Indian descent
of course it doesn't make sense and
literally pits one cultural group
against another all the peoples of our
nation have contributed to its Rich
fiber and deserve
recognition I don't have to educate this
honorable body as to the history of
Columbus Day it has little to do with
the one mercenary Merchant Mariner and
everything to do with ending
discrimination of it Italians after a
brutal Massacre lynchings by the way of
11 innocent Italian immigrants in New
Orleans in
1891 though no doubt president Harrison
when establishing that first Columbus
Day celebration in
1892 was trying to encourage the Italian
vote the effect of the holiday was a
shot in the arm to immigrants just like
my great-grandfather having hidden his
given name Gano and going by Thomas to
try and pass as American there was
finally a feeling of acceptance and that
maybe an end was in sight to blatant
bigotry Prejudice and
slurs all he wanted was to be seen as an
American and to raise his family as
honorable American citizens a plasterer
he lived with extended family 24 of them
in an Italian ghetto in Harlem New York
sharing one toilet while doing
backbreaking work of constructing
stately public buildings of New York
City all of which stand
today I just thank God he is an here to
see the statues of Columbus dozens of
them all over the country funded by poor
people like him torn to the ground
because of ignorance and continuing
anti-italian sentiment and to this I say
vergonia which means shame in Italian a
sponsorship of this bill in my beloved
State means only one thing that
discrimination against Americans of
Italian descent is still alive and well
in
2024 please put an end to this once and
for all table New Hampshire house bill
1335 indefinitely but I implore you do
more than that this year you legislated
curricula cursive and multiplication
tables it's sad that we need laws to
enforce Common Sense yet I applaud you
for taking necessary steps when common
sense is nowhere to be found here's a
perfect opportunity to legislate some
history and I don't mean anti-columbus
propaganda that students are being fed
by uninformed teachers require that our
public Educators not only celebrate
Columbus Day on the the second Monday of
October but teach children the facts of
origin and spend time honoring the
contributions of Italian immigrants in
building this nation in closing I ask
you honor Italian immigrants their
immense contributions and cultural
richness by killing this misguided Bill
honor my great-grandfather and all like
him and please understand that they
themselves would never in a million
years felt they were owed a day of
Celebration or reparations or statues
yet Safeguard this one day for us
because it's the great thing to do and I
think you know it thank you thank you
for your
testimony
Dio Deber
andu ah I oh
Al forgive
me look like a d
thank you madam chair and thank you
committee uh my name is Al brandano I'm
representing myself I'm also a part of
the group of friends of Italian
Americans here in New Hampshire and my
testimony is in front of you it's it's
about 5 minutes long I'm not going to do
that to you have it I'm just going to
I'm just going to paraphrase if you
don't mind um it's very interesting that
the woman earlier today opened up the
maker opened up a history uh and it's
kind of fitting for a minute if you'll
give me just 30 seconds it's about the
courage of Columbus and I want us all if
I can take you on a little journey if
you'll open your mind on this adventure
it's August 3 3rd 1492 nearly 500 years
ago cap Captain Columbus from Genoa
Italy and I would like to invite you and
join you on our first voyage of a
perilous and uous Adventure this mission
was to discover a new passage to perhaps
India or China for spices and to trade
aboard the ship fear stress is a
constant companion for us 86 crew
members spread across three tiny ships
not designed for ocean voyage
each tiny ship measured just between 50
and 70 ft from bow to stern in today's
equivalent the size of a trailer truck
we endured cramp quarters limited
hygiene facilities scurvy dissenter
constant exposure to the elements the
pro the prospect of falling off the edge
of the Earth or encountering mythical
sea creatures or facing hostile people
was very real to
us on October 12th 1492 35 days later
land ho I took the liberty of reading
the Captain's Log of Columbus on its
first voyage of course it was translated
I don't speak Italian that well but one
of the most things that that struck me
October 12 35 days later arriving in
what is today Cuba their first meeting
the inhabitants the following is the
exact words of Columbus in his log book
for the first voyage and discovery of
the
inhabitants that they might feel great
friendship for us he says and because I
knew they were a people who would be
better be freed and converted to our
Holy Faith by love rather than by force
that's his words so if we want to bring
up history That's
History the part I'd leave I'll I'll end
with here is who is behind really a
coordinated and Sinister scheme to
attack Columbus in Columbus Day the
attack on Columbus is is based on
distortions of his person and activities
that can be traced to the earliest
documents accounts rather of dasas Casa
the governorship of West Indies who
wrote exceedingly favorable about
Columbus D laasa was writing about the
atrocities of Francisco D bodella who
ousted Columbus from office by bringing
false claims against him which Columbus
defeated in
court not only did the crown find the
claims patent Le fals and did dismissed
them but they put their money where
their mouth was and funded the fourth
voyage this was followed by 1921 by
kuku's Clan along with addition of two
more modern sources the first a book by
Howard zin the people's History of the
United States because besi besides
Columbus Zin is a Marxist socialist he
is also condemned Abraham Lincoln
America and its allies in World War II
this book has been believed by many
people and is Affiliated in our schools
unjustly influencing our young people
second the attack on Columbus Day by
Victoria VZ from the takedown of
Columbus group who was determined to
remove statues and other positive
presentations of Columbus the following
is Robert Patron's response to
vquez even by today's impossible utopian
standards along with the passage of
Columbus Day as a federal Hall holid
nearly 132 years ago Columbus was
without doubt the greatest hero of the
15th and 16th centuries he was a
capitalist in the Age of Empires and
what he did begin the downfall
imperialism he was a scientist in the
age of superstition he was civil rights
activist in the age of Oppression and he
was a pacifist in the age of
warmongering thus Columbus was an icon
and a paragon of model a model of exence
in closing New Hampshire legislators
recognized the fact in 1929 in RSA
section 2881 adopted Columbus Day as a
state holiday so why now would you vote
to cancel Columbus Day and erase our
history and cancel our immigrant
sacrifices and memories now especially
in a time when the noble goals are
pursuing society's Mantra of
diversity Equity inclusion Justice and
coexistence are so popular please vote
against HB
1335 thank
you Frank
ferera repres represent do you answer a
question sir yes please representative
Brown thank you madam chair I'm
following up on what you said and I
think it I for following up on what you
said would it be accurate to say that
yes Columbus was imprisoned however he
was then transported back to Spain and
exonerated that is correct thank you
thank okay Frank
[Music]
Ferrero thank you madam chair um and
I'll summarize the more lengthy uh
testimony written testimony that I've
submitted uh good afternoon my name is
Frank Ferrero and I live in Northampton
I'm here today as a private citizen and
resident of New Hampshire testifying
against passage of HB
1335 like what you've heard today like
millions of poor immigrants from
Southern Italy my father's parents
immigrated to America at the turn of the
20th century my grandparents l landed on
Ellis Island with $2 in their pockets
and initially lived with my
grandfather's brother in The Little
Italy section of New York
City through their hard work they built
a life for themselves and their family
of nine
children allow me to provide a little
context why I oppose
1335 contrary to what we may have been
taught slavery didn't end in this C
country in
1865 slavery of Italian immigrants
continued into the early 20th century
through a system called the padron
system padron means boss or
Master newspapers carried stories about
Italian slavery from the late 1800s into
the first decade of the 20th
century the pedron act of
1874 was passed by Congress to end
Italian slavery in America nevertheless
the pedron system continued into the
20th century in places like Boston's
North
End in more than 40 occasions in the
late 19th century and early 20th century
lynch mobs took the law into their own
hands against Italian
immigrants the most outrageous of these
lynchings was the 1891 in lynching of 11
innocent Italians in New
Orleans that Massacre almost led us into
war with Italy and it moved president
Harrison to declare the first national
Columbus Day holiday on the 400th
anniversary of Columbus's Landing in
America at the outbreak of World War II
over
600,000 Italian immigrants suffered
curfews confiscations and mass
surveillance swept up in a wave of
racism and persecution
during World War
II in the 1960s and70s when the federal
government offered cities money for
urban renewal Portsmouth jumped at the
opportunity they chose the mostly
Italian North End for Renewal and began
demolition of hundreds of homes
sometimes only given days notice for
people to vacate their
houses the once cohesive Italian
Community was dispersed all over the Sea
Coast homes were destroyed even though
there were no plans for what would
replace them today 60 years after that
event there's still one lot that remains
vacant from urban renewal in
Portsmith I say all this not to try to
equate what happened to Italian
immigrants through the pedon system with
the disgrace and horrors of slavery of
Africans in America nor to imply that
other immigrants have not been treated
poorly but to illustrate that naming
Columbus Day as a holiday was an effort
to help heal the racism the lynchings
the discrimination and other
mistreatment of Italian immigrants and
their descendants have
endured I won't go into a long testimony
on Columbus the man suffice it to say
that much of what is taught today and
what you will hear and read through the
testimony on this bill about columus is
based upon writers who had an agenda and
use bits and pieces of primary sources
mixed together out of context and
meaning old age
shakes I'll get there excuse
me
here we
go Columbus wasn't a saint but he was a
good man and an Explorer and despite
what some people say he treated the
native people fairly and with
compassion and I appreciate your
question representative Brown Columbus
never spent time in a prison he was
immediately released by the queen and
and king of Spain upon reaching
Spain clus day holiday was declared to
honor people who were subject to
violence discrimination lynching slavery
and having their lives torn apart
Columbus Day is a celebration of what it
means to be the descendant of Italian
immigrants like most first and second
generation Americans of Italian descent
I'm proud of my Italian Heritage passage
of HB
1335 would be yet another insult to the
150,000 New Hampshire residents of
Italian descent and I urge you to find
the bill in expedient to legislate thank
you thank
you Paul
Monon
thank you all for the privilege of
testifying against hb1 335 my name is
Paul Monon I'm a proud citizen of New
Hampshire for 50 years and I very much
appreciate the service that all you give
to our
state uh to be frank I was surprised to
see the subject of eliminating Columbus
Day come up to our legislators again
since it has been defeated in the past
and to my knowledge there has been no
new developments on this
subject I certainly support the
testimony of others that you've heard uh
against this discrimination proposal and
will not repeat their information but I
would like to just bring out a few other
relevant
additions first is a photograph which is
being passed
out it is from
1938 it is my grandfather an Italian
immigrant and other Italian immigrants
sitting on the steps a of a church in
Scranton Pennsylvania where he and his
family lived please when you look at the
photograph note what these immigrants
are holding in their hands it is the
American
flag not withstanding the current Miss
by the way I should point out because a
few others brought out the World War II
I lost two uncles in World War II not
withstanding the current misinformation
on the character of Christopher Columbus
it is clear evidence that Columbus Day
was not a celebration of Columbus
himself as an idol but an expression of
uh against the expression to protect
these poor immigrants and it was an
expression of their gratitude for being
allowed to come to America and pursue
the American dream the Columbus
continues to be celebrated and gratitude
to our
immigrants uh by our immigrants for
being part of America and America's
thanks to them for their contributions
to our great
nation as I look around this
room uh presumably virtually all of you
are the descendants of immigrants from
some Nation Columbus Day is the only
holiday honoring our immigrants and I'm
at a loss to understand the reason for
potential eliminating it as a holiday
after 130 years as a national holiday
and almost 100 years as a holiday in
state of New Hampshire if you could
rationalize justifying deleting it
because it's named after Columbus
perhaps then we should eliminate the
District of Columbia Columbia University
the Knights of Columbus Columbus Ohio
and the 20 cities I'm sorry cities named
after him in 20 other states and other
uses of his name throughout our great
nation then we should perhaps consider
deleting other holidays for example
president St presidents had slaves the
4th of July celebrates colonialization
Christmas violates the separation of
church and state so in brief out of
respect for the best use of your time in
service to our
citizens which I deeply appreciate as I
mentioned I suggest that you delete this
attack on Columbus Day once and for all
thank you for your attention and
opportunity to
testify thank
you unfortunately we can't act beyond
the end of this
year I understand Lou
garula good afternoon Madame chairman
and committee members
my name is Lugar julo and I reside in
Hampton Falls New Hampshire where I
serve as a selectman and I'm also a
former member of the New Hampshire
General Court I my newest duty is I'm
one of the overseers and incorporating
members of the friends of Italian
Americans the friends of Italian
Americans was formed last year and in a
short period of time we have over 200
members and with the growth that's
taking place we expect to have a couple
of thousand in the next year I am here
representing myself today and our
members who stand with me in opposition
of HB
1335 I'll try to be as brief as possible
uh my father Luigi garula was born
outside of Naples Italy over a hundred
years ago he fought with American troops
in the liberation of Italy in World War
II immediately following the war he
immigrated to the United States as a
person growing up in Italy during the
Depression and the war my father longed
to follow the steps uh of another
Italian Christopher Columbus and come to
the New World although Christopher
Columbus did not discover North America
he was uh the founder really of the
Western Hemisphere his exploration and
knowledge gained was critical in
development of this part of the world we
are not here today to debate Christopher
Columbus we are here here today to
explain that millions of Italian
Americans and other groups who
immigrated from far away places view
Columbus Day as a day set aside to
remember and honor those who came before
us and to build our country to where it
is today they were the construction
workers the lawyers the doctors the
nurses the waiters the scientists the
teachers store owners soldiers and yes
politicians those who said in in
hollowed Halls of Congress and also in
the New Hampshire house stripping away
Columbus Day is an insult to millions
and millions of Americans who immigrated
here and who are a family of those who
did my father came here because he
believed in the American dream my father
lived the American dream I as a son have
also lived the American dream I built a
business from nothing and now employ
over 150 New Hampshire citizens my
children and my grandchildren are living
the American dream my daughter Colleen
is an army officer serving and she asked
me when I told her I was testifying
today to tell her she would love to have
been here and to tell you how she feels
about this part of the dream is to honor
and cherish our history and Columbus Day
is part of our our history I
respectfully ask you to find this bill
1335 inexpedient to legislate and let's
move on with more important things thank
you very much and have a great day thank
you is there anyone else wishes to
testify on House Bill
1335 all right seeing none I'll close
the public hearing and go into executive
session representative Simon thank you
madam chair I'd like to move in
expedient to legislate on H
Bill oh right representative Simon moves
in exped legis L represent Gro seconds
um you wish to speak to your motion yes
thank you madam chair um been waiting
into difficult subjects lately so I
might as well do this one as well
um I have I guess two points that I'd
like to make one I agree with a lot of
the testimony today that the present
iteration of history on Columbus is um
is inaccurate my own personal study
demonstrates him to be a man of Courage
U um a good man as a general rule um and
was certainly exonerated from uh from
his crimes um but the the main portion
main reason why I move in expedient to
legislate on this bill is um what a lot
of the testimony today kind of um spoke
to uh which is that uh America was
established to be an experiment of sorts
and and most of us are immigrants though
not all of us I mean there are some of
us who were Native um but many of us
were but is the one place that was
established with the idea that um people
from from every nation could come and be
free um and I feel like today uh the
attitude towards that is that that that
should be somehow easy that that's
within the nature of human beings um to
do that sort of thing and it isn't in
fact it's it's very much the opposite of
our nature to be inclusive and to
welcome and um to be able to work
together through our differences and
establish something um that is
worthwhile and Columbus Day is one of
the days that celebrates that I would
also add into that Martin Luther King Jr
day um which allegedly um has some
problems in his own history but
symbolizes that um with uh the black
community and also uh with St Patrick's
Day uh I know people celebrate things
for different reasons but with the Irish
as well um all symbolizing our struggle
to integrate together and and to bring
our different ideas and our different
Traditions um that sometimes rub the
wrong way uh with other people who have
already been established um but that we
would be able to come together as one
people group and so I see see those as
kind of a Triad of of our aspirations
and um to continue to celebrate them
would be to continue to Aspire um in
that way and so for those reasons I move
in expedient to legislate on this bill
and hope my colleagues will join me
representative
G thank you madam chair um this T type
of Bill or a bill similar of this has
come for before us many times and I
think that if there had been some sort
of change of information or
sentiment we might reconsider but I
think I agree with the motion and I'm
sure that the house will support that as
well so I um that's all I have to say
thank you all right
representative
Smith Madam chair um I don't go along
with this well I do go along with the
bill I'm I I understand about the attack
Italians and what they have done for
America and I agree with everything you
said representative Simon however
couldn't we change the name of the bill
get Columbus out of it change the name
of the bill and call it an
Italian okay representative Grotto would
like to respond to that okay that's fine
so last year on the house the floor I'm
I
specifically presented that floor
Amendment
and it was defeated by the house so the
house does not wish to change the name
of Columbus Day to Italian Heritage day
in that case then Okay
g Madam chair and thank you
representative Simon for a beautiful
Bill though I was mistaken in my earlier
motion on what Bill we were on my
intention was to um to move itl on
13 and I am uh a proud abanaki woman my
first husband was Ronnie Scara from the
North End of Boston my daughter is
pursuing her Italian citizenship though
she's already uh a citizen of the
abanaki um the nagan band of the kosak
abanaki nation and of course a citizen
of the United
States I think that it is very sad that
this whole disc discussion has pitted a
or Native American people against
Italian people we are uh all people and
we have no reason to hate one another
and we have no re reason for hard
feelings toward one another and we have
lots of reasons not just how much I love
my ex-husband or how much I love my
daughter but uh we have lots of reasons
to to not let a small faction of our
society turn us against one another so I
fully support itl on this bill
Madam oh thank you madam chair um most
of the testimony and what L garolo
mentioned that this is really not about
Columbus the
person uh I I I appreciate all of that I
I would like to address however because
it was it was brought up in the initial
presentation of the bill a couple of
comments that I'd like to address
although I have never read Washington
Irvings biography of Christal Columbus
has done some reading as representative
Simon has said so I want to I want to
clarify what I think were several points
made in the original
presentation um when Columbus did come
to the New World there was a huge uh
decrease in the population not because
Columbus
and uh others went out and slaughtered
everyone it was because mainly because
disease that was brought to this this
part of the of the World by the
Europeans and and there was a a also an
issue where Columbus was defending some
of the tribes that were being subjected
to cannibalism by other
tribes that's one of them so there was a
reduction of population but an inference
that that Columbus uh eliminated all
those people I think in my estimation it
is accurate R talked about the prison uh
the prison sentence and the
exoneration um also certainly we know
now that there were others that had
discovered uh this continent but at that
time and and celebrating the fact that
Columbus was a brave person and
discovered a continent that no one knew
was here at the time was very accurate
the Europeans at that
time did not know that there was a
continent here so to say that it
everyone kind of kind of knew this
already and Columbus was not a brave
Mariner for that I think is inaccurate
as
well
um and I think I think that's all I had
the other pieces of been touched on so
thank you madam chair okay all right I
I'd like to make two
points and the first is that we keep
tearing down our heroes because they
aren't
perfect and that's something that it's
it's our fault for expecting the people
who accomplish things to be perfect if
they're human they're not going to be
perfect and the other thing is that
regardless of the fact that other people
had visited this continent from the
Vikings to St Columban was it St Brandon
St brandan I
think it was Columbus and his
voyages that started the integration of
the Western Hemisphere with the Eastern
Hemisphere and that changed the whole
world forever and I think we need to
recognize that regardless of any issues
of the person or people
involved um so I am definitely going to
be supporting the
itl anyone else all right we've all
speeed by um the motion is in expedient
to legislate by representative Simon and
the clerk can call the role
representative Simon yes representative
lakas yes representative Bailey yes
clerk votes yes representative Boyd yes
representative
Brown yes representative groa yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
Smith
noes Manti
yes and the chair
yes 14 yay one nay all right the motion
of itl passes 14 to one is there any
objection to
consent representative Schmidt objects
to consent so we'll put this on the
regular
calendar I wish to speak to my objection
to consent this is
uh this is a perennial bill which has
the very
unfortunate effect of being seen as
anti-italian it's clearly anti-columbus
uh for reasons which we can uh argue and
dispute U with regard to every aspect of
his character his accomplishments and so
forth um it certainly is an
anti-columbus
Bill and but it is
inextricably seen by Italian Americans
as an anti Italian American Bill
denigrating their Great accomplishments
and contri contributions to this country
that is extremely unfortunate because uh
I'm sure that none of us uh think that
there's any Merit whatsoever in the idea
of Italian Americans not having made
magnificent contributions not only to
World culture but to this country across
the board if if
if I if I had to measure how much
spaghetti I've eaten I'm certainly more
than 100% Italian just in the last year
but in any case uh the reality is that
that this bill and that's one of the
reasons that it should be on the regular
calendar that the whole house should be
have an opportunity to vote no on the
idea of um of that that this house is in
any way a party to the idea that
italian-americans have not made enormous
contributions on the one hand but also
suffered greatly as has virtually every
other non uh non indigenous population
and they have their own suffering to to
uh be uh to be cognizant of so I think
the whole house should vote no on
this thank you that's easy enough all
right I think we finished our executive
session and we are done for the day and
I will see you all tomorrow in session
and next week we're on
vacation